zusammen zu zdf heute live euren live
stream zu aktuellen ereignissen und
diskussionen und eigentlich wollten wir
jetzt gleich nach brüssel schalten zur
pressekonferenz der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur ema aber der stream
lief gerade schon und die push meldung
war schon draußen da haben wir einen
anruf aus brüssel bekommen dass sich die
pressekonferenz noch mal verschiebt
jetzt wohl um eine stunde das heißt um
17 uhr soll es dadurch gehen ihr seid
trotzdem nicht völlig umsonst hier
denn ich möchte trotzdem kurz reden mit
meinem gast dr christoph specht
medizinjournalist die nicht jetzt im
stile größe hallo herr doktor specht
hallo oder mainz christi so jetzt ist
die pressekonferenz verschoben worden
auch die pressekonferenz von
bundesgesundheitsminister jetzt sparen
so ist das wort das ist heute schon
verschoben worden das klingt also so als
ob das alles doch nicht ganz so
eindeutig wäre mit diesen astrazeneca
impfstoff oder also das kann natürlich
sein dass man es ganz besonders genau
dem das kann natürlich auch ganz profane
gründe haben warum so eine
pressekonferenz mal verschoben werden
muss nehmen wir mal an dass die behörden
jetzt wirklich sehr genau arbeiten und
wirklich alles noch mal wenden und
drehen besonders genau anschauen
man hat ja so ein gewisses gefühl was
denn passieren könnte die wahrscheinlich
dass der wahrscheinlichste szenario wird
ja wahrscheinlich sein dass man sagt ja
astrazeneca kann weiter vertieft werden
aber vielleicht unter einschränkungen
es wäre schon eine überraschung wenn die
ehemals die ja noch gestern auch gesagt
hat sie sieht eigentlich kein
zusammenhang beziehungsweise kein grund
den astra zeneca impfstoff nicht zu
empfehlen und die bedingte zulassung die
ja hat wieder zurückzunehmen also das
wäre schon eine überraschung aber eine
einschränkung bei den personen für die
der astrazeneca impfstoffen und geeignet
ist oder nicht die könnte es schon geben
dann möchten wir müssen mal kurz über
diesen stopp sprechen der ja in
zahlreichen europäischen ländern
vollzogen wurde ich habe einmal
aufgeschrieben unter anderem dänemark
norwegen island portugal frankreich und
auch bei uns in deutschland fanden sie
diesen stopp nachvollziehbar
nachvollziehbar schon ich denke
allerdings man hätte auch anders
entscheiden können
die ema hat ja die aufgabe solche dinge
zu untersuchen
wie hat sich ja auch schon dazu geäußert
natürlich haben wir auch in deutschland
institute wie das paul-ehrlich-institut
ist ja auch ein bundeseigenes institut
und die schau ja schon genau hin was war
passiert es waren eben diese relativ
sowieso seltenen sinus venenthrombosen
aufgetaucht wie sind schon selten und
jetzt waren hier eben mehr aufgetaucht
als diese seltenen zu erwarten gewesen
wären und dann ist eben auch so ein
seltenes risiko doch irgendwie bedeutsam
denn wenn man sagen mal damit rechnet in
12 wochen ein fall normalerweise davon
zu sehen und man sieht dann in einer
woche aber doch 34 56 fälle und die sind
alle bei menschen aufgetaucht die
geimpft worden sind dann muss man da
schon mal ein bisschen genauer hingucken
was man natürlich hätte machen können
weil es eben ein sehr sehr sehr geringes
risiko ist auch eine geringe erhöhung
der hätte man natürlich sagen können wir
impfen weiter untersuchen natürlich
trotzdem dies untersuchen hatte ja auch
schon vorher begonnen man hat sich aber
hier anders entschieden wahrscheinlich
wollte man auch vertrauen damit aufbauen
ob es gelungen ist werden wir sehen ich
würde aber gerade auch dieses risiko
mehr eingehen denn wenn wir jetzt uns
anschauen wir haben steigende incidents
zahlen die vermutlich wenn wir uns die
zahl der positiven pcr-test angucken
nicht mehr darauf zurückzuführen sind
dass einfach gerade mehr getestet wird
das heißt das infektionsgeschehen
breitet sich aus das scheint vor allem
die britische variante zu sein die sich
hier in deutschland exponentielle
vermehrt gleichzeitig sind die schulen
und kindergärten geöffnet sind jetzt
wieder teilweise die geschäfte offen
auch wenn es nur dieses klick und miet
konzept ist da ist auch das risiko dass
man sich einer corona infektion einfängt
sehr viel höher würde ich erst mal so
als laie behaupten als dass man sich mit
bei diesem astrazeneca impfstoff so eine
thrombose einfängt oder das ist
tatsächlich so ja das kann man sagen vor
allen dingen für bestimmte altersgruppen
gilt das natürlich wir kennen ja die
risikogruppen für einen schweren
hus-verlauf das sind eben die älteren
wenn dann noch vorerkrankungen dazu
kommen erst recht das risiko ist extrem
hoch es ist nicht so hoch bei jungen
menschen und was wir jetzt hier gesehen
haben diese nebenwirkung bei astrazeneca
hat ja gerade er jüngere betroffen da
könnte man natürlich sagen na ja also
jetzt habe ich eine 20 jährige frau
die möglicherweise ein erhöhtes risiko
für diese nebenwirkungen des impfstoffs
hat wenn sich das so herausstellt und
auf der anderen seite hat sie aber ein
relativ geringes risiko einen schweren
verlauf er eine kubik 19 erkrankung zu
bekommt also hier muss man eben
eindeutig abwägen und hier sieht man
eben auch dass das immer eine frage der
abwägung ist 100 prozent nutzen und
überhaupt kein risiko das gibt es fast
nie und auch bei diesem impfstoff ist es
offensichtlich so wenn sich das
bewahrheitet dann muss man eben die
abwägung machen zwischen risiko für
einen schweren verlauf und risiko dieser
nebenwirkung aber trotzdem entsteht der
eindruck jetzt in der dass die politik
das eine risiko in kauf nimmt und wieder
eröffnet und in kauf nimmt dass die
institute zahlen die dann nach oben
schnellen die krankenhäuser wieder voll
werden was ja überhaupt niemand wollen
kann auf der anderen seite dann doch
über vorsichtig reagiert das ist ja doch
irgendwie paradox oder ja da ist was
dran in der tat und ich glaube das liegt
daran dass wir diese risiken einfach
nicht wirklich klar vor augen sehen das
ist auch gar nicht so einfach mit dieser
statistik statistik da steigen ja die
meisten eben auch gerne aus auch
mediziner im studium gehören der
statistik nicht so gerne hin weil es
dann dort komplizierter klingt aber es
ist natürlich wichtig sich damit zu
beschäftigen um genau eben solche
unterschiede auch erkennen zu können
noch einen kleinen punkt zu diesen
öffnungen die zahlen die steigende
zahlen die wir jetzt sehen die sind
denke ich nicht auf einen einzigen
umstand zurückzuführen also nicht auf
vermehrte tests ja es gibt vermehrt test
das mag ein anteil haben aber
wahrscheinlich keinen großen vor allem
glaube ich aber nicht dass die
beschlossenen lockerungen jetzt schon
den anteil haben das werden wir erst
noch sehen
denn die zahlen die wir jetzt sehen die
müssen schon früher entstanden sein
sprich das sind die vorweggenommenen
lockerungen also das was die menschen
eben tatsächlich tun
ich sage immer so dem virus ist ja
völlig egal was seine regierung
beschließt das virus das guckt drauf was
wir menschen tatsächlich machen und man
hat ja gespürt in den letzten wochen das
ist so ein lockerungs gedanken gab in
der bevölkerung man wollte einfach jetzt
mal wieder raus und hatte auch gehofft
dass man ein bisschen raus kann und
trotzdem sinken die zahlen das hat sich
nicht bewahrheitet gott sei dank sind
die todeszahlen aber doch zurück
gegangen und nicht weiter gestiegen aber
dass auch die frage ob das nicht jetzt
wenn die
incidents zahlen wieder steigen nicht
doch dem nachgelagert dann kommt das
dauert ja auch immer ein paar wochen wir
haben jetzt hier einige fragen an sie
oder auch zu diesen impfstoff bevor wir
da aber ein einsteigen weil uns wir doch
in unseren paar minuten doch nehmen
wollen mal schauen vielleicht wird die
pressekonferenz noch vorverlegt oder wir
brechen den stream oder pendenten den
dann gleich und schauen uns um 17 uhr
dann noch mal an was da an brüssel
beschlossen wurde das haben wir grade
noch nicht so richtig beschlossen hier
in der redaktion jetzt weiter vorgehen
wollen wir nochmal einmal kurz gucken
was da eigentlich passiert ist mit
diesem astrazeneca impfstoff da hat
meine kollegin dina niebergall eine
kleine zusammenfassung gemacht es ging
so gut los
die ankündigung im august vergangenen
jahres astrazeneca will die eu mit 400
millionen dosen beliefern doch schon die
erste lieferung macht probleme
der pharmakonzern hat
lieferschwierigkeiten die eu bekommt
deutlich weniger als erwartet
gleichzeitig verunsichern meldungen über
die wirksamkeit bei und ex kaiser und
moderner haben eine wirksamkeit von über
90 prozent astrazeneca etwa 60 prozent
und dann auch noch das kurz vor der
zulassung empfiehlt die ständige
impfkommission astrazeneca nur für
menschen bis 64 jahren die zulassung
kommt trotzdem am 30 januar diesen
jahres im februar schon ist klar gegen
die südafrikanische virus mutation
schützt der impfstoff nur begrenzt
geimpft wird weiter irgendwann auch an
ältere menschen bis vor wenigen tagen
dänemark stoppt die impfung als erstes
weitere eu länder folgen schließlich
auch deutschland die impfung könnte in
zusammenhang mit hirn thrombosen stehen
und deswegen eben der stopp der impfung
in vielen europäischen ländern darüber
spreche ich gerade mit dem
medizinjournalisten dr christoph specht
ich schau mal hier in die kommentare da
gibt es ja sehr viel für und wider wie
das gerade auch generell der fall ist es
scheint wirklich so eine art
lagerbildung zu geben bei ganz vielen
themen hubert müller schreibt zum
beispiel wandel sputnik wie endlich in
europa zugelassen wir brauchen endlich
bessere alternativen
darauf gibt es dann eine antwort ein
paar kommentare darunter den finde ich
das gerade nicht aber da ging in die
richtung ich finde es lustig als an
sputnik widerrufen der auf ja genau so
ein weg der impfstoff ist wie
astrazeneca also auf der gleichen
medizintechnologie beruft beruht dann
gibt es stimmen die sagen wenn dieser
impfstoff wieder zugelassen wird dann
gehe ich kaputt dass mein steffi müller
2 kommentare darunter schreibt tutorials
formal video ich gehe stark davon aus
dass zugelassen wird und das hoffe ich
auch jeder kann sich ja damit impfen ob
er will oder nicht ich würde gerne herr
doktor specht würden sie diesen
impfstoff nehmen
ich würde die nehmen ja es wäre nicht
meine erste wahl sage ich ganz ehrlich
aber wenn ich nur diesen impfstoff
angeboten bekomme würde ich ihn nehmen
weil ich eben hat für mich selbst eine
risikoabwägung mache und nach den daten
die mir vorliegen ist nach wie vor ein
guter impfstoff weil er eine sehr gute
immunantwort produziert das ist ja
eigentlich das was wir wollen übrigens
auch der grund dafür warum astrazeneca
gerade bei der ersten impfung na ja zum
teil schon größere impfreaktionen zeigt
eigentlich keine nebenwirkungen sondern
das ist ja gerade ausdruck der impfung
also diese abgeschlagenheit manchmal
auch erbrechen fieber kopfweh all das
spricht für eine starke immunantwort und
vom prinzip ist das dass das was wir
wollen
jetzt gibt es hier zum beispiel aber die
entgegnung von maria hölzl auf youtube
statistik ist extrem von einer guten
datenlage abhängig und das haben wir
hier definitiv nicht würden sie das auch
so sehen
nein das würde ich eigentlich so sehen
denn ich meine diese impfung ist ja eine
die in der geschichte der menschheit
noch nie so gut betrachtet worden ist
und so engmaschig betrachtet worden ist
alleine schon wegen der aufmerksamkeit
aber auch wegen der möglichkeiten der
technischen möglichkeiten also ich denke
schon dass diese acht fälle die es jetzt
ja sind so aufgefallen sind bei 16
millionen verengten oder geimpften
menschen wird das finde ich eigentlich
schon eher ein beweis dafür dass man da
doch genau hinguckt selbstverständlich
kann irgendwo in der welt könnten fälle
sein die wir da nicht entdecken und die
nicht berichtet werden
selbstverständlich aber insgesamt habe
ich nicht den eindruck dass da
irgendetwas von der datenlage her nicht
ausreichend wäre
nichtsdestotrotz
scheint es ja so ein bisschen wasser auf
die mühlen derjenigen zu sein die schon
seit wochen oder monaten davor warnen
dass dieser impfstoff dass diese
impfstoffe nicht ausreichend erforscht
sind dass sie nicht genug testete dass
man gar nicht genug weiß dann ist immer
von langzeit wirkungen die rede
dieses wort ist ja dann auch
missverständlich ganz häufig benutzt
worden weil das heißt er eigentlich
nicht das was wir als im alltagsgebrauch
damit meinen aber trotzdem die frage
dass diese in fraktionen oder diese
unerwünschten reaktionen wenn sie in
einem zusammenhang mit dem impfstoff
stehen muss man ja dazu sagen also wenn
du jetzt aufgetaucht sind
hätte man das mit noch mehr testungen
nicht herausfinden müssen oder können
nein hätte man nicht können weil wenn
sie schauen so eine impfstoff
untersuchungen studie findet statt wenn
es eine große ist wie das jetzt bei all
diesen impfstoffen hier war mit 20 40
tausend probanden das ist schon eine
ganz große zahl aber bei 20 40 tausend
probanden
da können sie so eine seltene
nebenwirkung wie diese gar nicht
entdecken also es ist überhaupt kein
wunder wenn jetzt nicht aufgetaucht ist
und man muss 1 mal sehen auch die
anderen impfstoffe die zugelassen sind
haben zum teil seltene heftige
nebenwirkungen oder folgen reaktionen
bis hin zum tod so das kann vorkommen es
ist extrem selten im millionenbereich
aber es kann vorkommen und das war von
anfang an da das habe ich übrigens schon
vor einem jahr gesagt da war von
impfstoffen nur die rede dass man daran
forscht lassen wenn sie zugelassen
werden und so großflächig verimpft
werden wir reden ja hier von milliarden
menschen geimpft werden
dass es da nicht ausbleiben kann es auch
ganz seltene nebenwirkungen irgendwann
irgendwie auftauchen und man dann
feststellt unter d und e und der
konstellation kann eben das und das
passieren aber hier ist es ebenso wir
müssen die risiken abwägen nullrisiko
gibt es in keinem fall und wer sagt nein
also auch dieses kleine risiko ist mir
einfach zu groß ich mach das nicht dann
gehe ich lieber das risiko ein eine
kopie 19 erkrankung zu bekommen von der
ich annehme dass ich sie nicht bekommen
dann ist das die individuelle
entscheidung ein arzt hat da nicht in
die entscheidung ihn einzufangen er kann
aufklären aber der patient bzw der zu
impfenden entscheidet selbst das ist
jetzt auch tatsächlich jeder fall also
hier gibt es sowohl
die wortmeldungen von anja es zb die
sagt jetzt schreibt ich mache das nicht
das risiko ist mir zu hoch ich mag ihr
das mal hier gerade ich habe keinen bock
auf gehirnblutungen so nah und dann habe
ich aber auch gerade darüber den
kommentar von ex-bayer gelesen nur weil
eine brücke potenziell einstürzen kann
entscheide ich mich auch nicht über
einen see zu schwimmen ich will als impf
gruppe 4 einfach nur endlich einen
absehbaren impftermin bekommen ich habe
auch gerade schon kommentare gelesen die
gegen ihnen die richtung ich bin mit
astra geimpft worden ich habe jetzt
angst also tatsächlich frage ich mich
auch
es wird auch viel berichtet natürlich
über über diesen impfstoff das ist
unsere aufgabe unsere pflicht aber wird
dann nicht auch ein risiko zu hoch
bewertet und zu hoch gepusht das
vielleicht ja bei sieben opfern auf 1,6
millionen impfungen relativ gering ist
wie würden sie das sehen das auch ein
bisschen mit dem blick auf die mediale
berichterstattung herr doktor spricht ja
es ist nun mal so dass wir in einer zeit
leben in der eben jede zahl jede meldung
jedes gremium was irgendwo sich
zusammentrifft dass jedes kleine
plötzlichen berichtet wird das hat
vorteile wenn man mit diesen daten
umgehen kann es hat aber auch große
nachteile wenn das eben nicht der fall
ist und die daten liegen ja auf dem
tisch also das was wir jetzt hier sehen
ist eben eine risikoerhöhung und je
nachdem wie viele fälle man jetzt
zusammen nimmt 0,00 0 4 oder 0 0005 das
risiko existiert das ist da jetzt kann
man natürlich anders ausrechnen wie hoch
ist das risiko eine kuh wie 19
erkrankung zu bekommen da kommt es aufs
alter darauf an wenn sie 80 jahre alt
sind dann haben sie ein mehr als 600
fach erhöhtes risiko für einen tödlichen
verlauf im vergleich zu einem 20
jährigen also das sind natürlich einfach
große unterschiede
und natürlich wenn ich jetzt 20 bin und
sage mein gott das scheint für mich
nicht so relevant zu sein ist in den
meisten fällen richtig aber es gibt
natürlich auch 20-jährige auch völlig
ohne vorerkrankungen die es hart
erwischt das ist immer eine abwägung und
wir müssen halt wieder dazu kommen dass
leben als eine abwägung zwischen nutzen
und risiko zu sehen null risiko ist
einfach nicht vorgesehen das hat nicht
eine regierung erfunden das ist einfach
so
es gibt sie auch den kommentar von backa
xy man braucht nun wirklich keine angst
zu haben jede schmerztablette hat eine
höhere wahrscheinlichkeit für
nebenwirkungen als diese impfung würde
ich jetzt mal ergänzen dann gab es ja
auch immer wieder die verweise auf die
antibabypille hier auch durchaus das
risiko von thrombosen beinhaltet oder
von depressionen von von anderen
schwierigkeiten da hat dann karl
lauterbach davor gewarnt das miteinander
zu vergleichen kann man also wieso kann
man das nicht miteinander vergleichen
oder warum sollte man das nicht
miteinander vergleichen
also ich sag immer vergleichen kann man
alles miteinander nur gleichsetzen das
wäre ein fehler
es sind beides thrombosen die hier
auftreten bei der antibabypille können
übrigens auch sinus - thrombosen
auftauchen
meistens sind aber damit tiefe
beinvenenthrombose gemeint dass er so
ein gerinnsel in den tiefen beinvenen
und durch bewegung dann kann sich so ein
gerinnsel losreißen und wird dann mit
dem blutstrom ins herz transportiert da
passiert noch nichts aber dann ein paar
sekunden später landete das in der lunge
und da ist sie die geschichte einfach zu
klein ist verstopft die lungen das kann
so lungenembolie kommen die übrigens
auch tödlich enden kann
diese sinus venenthrombose ist insofern
was anderes ist auch eine thrombose aber
es findet halt schon mal im hirn statt
und hat letztendlich dann folgen durch
diese stimmung so ähnlich wie bei einem
schlaganfall das kann auch zu
epileptischen anfällen kommen ich würde
beides nicht haben wollen eine
lungenembolie ist kein spaß und eine
sinus venenthrombose nicht es gibt aber
auch ein drittel der sinus
venenthrombosen die ja wie gesagt
relativ selten sind die symptomatisch
verlaufen das heißt da merken die
patienten noch nicht mal etwas von aber
die anderen zwei drittel schon und bei
etwa 10 15 prozent bleiben dann auch
noch symptome zurück also beides hat so
insofern miteinander zu tun weil beides
thrombosen sind aber vielleicht als
letztes noch das was jetzt ebenso
auffällig war weil dieser astrazeneca
geschichte war das zu dieser sinus
venenthrombose hinzu kam dieses
herabgesetzten dieser blutplättchen also
der thrombozyten und diese kombination
die ist schon ganz ganz besonders und
hat eben dann doch aufhorchen lassen
das können sie uns vielleicht noch mal
im detail erklären ich möchte ganz kurz
allen zuschauer innen die jetzt gerade
dazu gefunden haben mitteilen das dauert
hier noch ein bisschen bis wir
tatsächlich
mit der pressekonferenz starten können
vielleicht einmal kamera wechseln liebe
kollegen auch die kamera hier auf die
zwei dankeschön weil eigentlich war
angepeilt das um 16 uhr sich die
europäische arzneimittelagentur zum
astrazeneca impfstoff und dessen
gefährlichkeit oder dessen risiko ihre
einschätzung äußert diese
pressekonferenz ist kurz vor unserem
stream um eine stunde verschoben wurden
auf 17 uhr der
bundesgesundheitsministeriums sparen
möchte sich wohl auch noch äußern
vermutlich im anschluss das heißt auch
das wird sich noch mal nach hinten
verschieben ich spreche gerade mit dr
christoph specht medizinjournalist über
diesen astrazeneca impfstoff und über
das für und wider von impfungen fragen
könnt ihr uns sehr gerne in den
kommentaren lassen
ich denke wir werden in streamen einfach
offen lassen vielleicht zwischendurch
pausieren und warten was die
pressekonferenz gibt also sammelt euch
hier gerne sagt weiter dass wir streamen
und versuchen fragen zu beantworten
aus medizinischer kompetenter hand so
sie haben es gerade schon mal
angesprochen wie das ganze vorsicht
läuft ich zeig mal kurz jetzt könnte auf
meinen scream schalten auf meinen screen
schalten die wir kollegen es gab hier
nämlich einen twitter-feed der ist diese
woche total gegangen von aliens dorf das
ist ein anästhesist leitender notarzt
des klinikums schaumburg und der hat
hier in einem langen brett sehr
wissenschaftlich erklärt was dort
passiert ist bei diesen muss ich noch
mal bei der thrombozytopenie und hat
eine hypothese aufgestellt jetzt möchte
ich diesen schritt nicht vorlesen
sondern weil ja auch sehr
wissenschaftlich ist sondern unseren
experten tragen der doktor specht
könnten sie das mal zusammenfassen in
einem für medizinische laien
verständlichen deutsch was der kollege
dort aufgeschrieben hat was seine
hypothese ist und was sie davon halten
ja ganz genau sie haben es richtig
gesagt das ist eine hypothese und es
gebührt diesen kollegen wirklich viel
ehre das hat er ganz toll gemacht dass
so zusammenzustellen
was ist passiert er hat sich angeguckt
um welche fälle es da geht wir haben als
auf der einen seite die sinus
venenthrombose das ist das abschluss
gebiet blut applaus gebiet vom blut aus
dem hirn die lokalisation wo dieser
thrombus eben war und wir haben ja das
zweites dabei eben dieses weniger werden
oder fehlen
blutplättchen den sogenannten
thrombozyten diese thrombozyten sind
dafür da das blut also ein teil davon
um die um das ein thrombus zu bilden
also um das blut an der stelle eine
offene stelle zum beispiel abzudichten
jetzt ist es ja eigentlich komisch auf
der einen seite haben ein blutpfropf
also erhöhte gerinnung auf der anderen
seite haben wir keine thrombozyten das
ist ja passt ja erstmal nicht zusammen
aber in diesem modell passt es schon
zusammen es hat sich nämlich gezeigt
dass diese menschen die diese sinus
venenthrombose haben gleichzeitig auf
der haut so kleine floh stich artige
blutungen hatten und dies findet man
typischerweise bei einer so genannten
thrombozytopenie was zu deutsch nichts
anderes heißt als wenige blutplättchen
man erkennt dieses syndrom das nennt
sich hit abgekürzt hat wirklich schöner
als ss heparin induzierte
thrombozytopenie was ist damit gemeint
man gibt eine menschen heparin das kennt
man ja um das blut flüssiger zu machen
um es einfach zu sagen
und dieses heparin sollte also das blut
besser fließen lassen in dem fall
passiert aber das gegenteil
es bilden sich bestimmte antikörper die
aktivieren die blutplättchen die werden
dadurch verbraucht und es bildet sich
ein thrombus jetzt da haben wir also ein
traum ist eine thrombose an einer stelle
im körper in einem gefäß eben in diesem
beispiel der sinus wien der sinus vene
und auf der anderen seite fehlen dann
die thrombozyten und deswegen führt das
zum beispiel an der haut zu diesen
kleinen punktförmigen blutungen
genau so etwas vermutet man dass es die
hypothese dieses kollegen und die halte
ich für sehr plausibel
genau dieses phänomen vermutet man jetzt
hier auch das heißt durch die impfung
werden ja antikörper gebildet und
möglicherweise bei einer bestimmten
konstellation da ganz ganz wenigen
menschen kann es sein dass eben auch
antikörper gebildet werden die diese
blutplättchen aktivieren können viel
mehr als gut ist und deswegen ist zu
einer solchen thrombose kommt und
gleichzeitig zu diesen fluchtartigen
blutungen aber das jetzt zu erforschen
tatsächlich das wissenschaftlich
verdingt festzumachen das wird
wahrscheinlich noch sehr viel zeit
dauern oder das dauert ja und viele
glauben ja das wäre die aufgabe der emea
sei der europäischen arzneimittelbehörde
und wie soll sie das in zwei tagen
machen nein das macht die natürlich
nicht sondern die schaut sich die daten
an die schaut ob der statistisch
auffällig ist mit diesem syndrom wasser
aufgetaucht ist den symptomen
ob das sein kann ob das
hintergrundrauschen ist also wie in der
physik dass man sagt das passiert
sowieso könnte mit der impfung oder muss
mit der impfung gar nichts zu tun haben
oder ist das eben doch auffällig und ich
vermute man wird sagen doch das ist
schon ein bisschen auffällig und
deswegen muss man hingucken aber die
pathophysiologie sozusagen also erklären
wie kann es denn dazu gekommen sein
das bleibt an einer weiteren forschung
übrig so jetzt habe ich hier jede menge
fragen zu verschiedenen aspekten dieser
impfung
ich fange mal mit einer wortmeldung an
von msi wedele das risiko an einer
narkose zu sterben ist wesentlich höher
stoppt die eu auch op es also eine etwas
ironisch sarkastisch gemeinten frage die
wir jetzt nicht beantworten müssen aber
tatsächlich ist das risiko bei einer
narkose glaube ich signifikant höher
herr doktor specht oder als bei diesen
impfstoff ja es kommt darauf an welche
großen mann macht aber es gibt ganz
vieles was wir jeden tag tun wo das
risiko natürlich auch für todt viel viel
höher ist klar es ist eben ein abwägen
zwischen risiko oder nutzen und risiko
dann gibt es hier eine wortmeldung von
ge schröder tod stimmt impfstoff oder
lebend impfstoff ist wurde für ein leben
impfstoff entschieden ein leben dem
stoff kommt nicht in meinen körper ist
das wirklich die nein nein das nicht
richtig
selbst auf der seite des verbands der
forschenden mittel industrie vfh stand
das eine zeitlang das adenoviren
impfstoffe ein erleben impfung wären das
war damals gedacht als man noch nicht
wusste dass es nur den vektor wir und
impfstoffe geben wird die sich gar nicht
verlieren können damals gab es auch noch
das konzept das das vermehrungsfähige
sind was ist ein leben leben von der
lebend impfung ist wenn ich ein virus
nehmen immer bei gelbfieber an also ein
virus das gelbfieber die
fiebererkrankung sehr ernste erkrankung
auslöst und das schwäche ich so sehr ab
dass es sich zwar noch vermehren kann
aber nicht mehr diese böse krankheit
machen kann das ist eine lebende impfung
die dürfen zum beispiel menschen mit
einer autoimmunerkrankung nicht bekommen
weil das könnte schiefgehen
dieses diese adenovirus das ist ein bios
dem man die fähigkeit sich zu vermehren
genommen hat das ist nur ein vehikel man
kann sich das so vorstellen
innen drin ist das genmaterial was man
haben möchte wieso im lkw drin und das
adenovirus selbst ist der lkw den ich
brauche um eben in den körper zu fahren
um in die körperzellen zu fahren
nachdem der lkw das adenovirus in dieser
zelle ist geht es kaputt dass vermehrt
sich eben nicht deswegen ist es keine
leben in rom
so jetzt haben wir uns schon die ersten
nicht nennen sie mal astrazeneca fans
also nach den drosten ultras gibt es
jetzt die ersten wortmeldungen
ich brauche nicht tralala gebt mir
astrazeneca geräumt wird auch noch sehr
schön christine die nächste behauptung
die ich gerne von ihnen fakten checken
lassen möchte von ugly durch die
impfungen entstehen mehr mutationen die
dann viel gefährlicher werden auch für
geimpfte stimmt das so würde ich nicht
unterschreiben aber ich denke was der
zuschauer hier meint es folgen das
tatsächlich ist das so ein virus was auf
naive menschen naiv im sinne von immun
naiv das heißt sie haben noch keinen
kontakt mit diesem virus gehabt trifft
hat keinen grund sich großartig zu
verändern so war das ja auch am anfang
weil alle menschen
sap titel sind wie man menschen sagen
würde also empfänglich für dieses virus
dann klappt das wenn jetzt immer mehr
menschen immun dagegen sind sei es durch
die durchgemachte infektion die das zum
beispiel in brasilien der fall war oder
durch impfungen dann muss ich ich war
menschlich dass jetzt mal das virus was
überlegen dann muss es sagen das
immunsystem und durch diese impfungen
die haben mich schon erkannt da komme
ich nicht mehr weiter ich muss mich mal
irgendwie verändern
man nennt das dann auch escape
mutationen die sind nicht gleich von
jetzt auf nachher 100 prozent also dass
das immunsystem es überhaupt nicht mehr
erkennen würde aber es wird schwächer er
kann zb wird ja auch die britische
variante schon ein bisschen schwächer
erkannt und auch die vor allem
brasilianische variante wird schwächer
erkannt irgendwann wird es mal eine
mutation geben die dann wirklich
überhaupt nicht mehr erkannt wird eine
komplette escape mutation aber das ist
noch nicht der fall vom prinzip hat der
zuschauer recht aber gerade deswegen ist
es so wichtig dass wir zügig mit dem
impfen sind ich mache mal extrem wenn
das gelungen wäre
anfang der pandemie innerhalb der ersten
vier wochen acht wochen alle menschen
auf der welt zu impfen oder sophie leben
das der herdenimmunität erreicht ist
dann wäre der käse gegessen dann hätte
das virus keine chance make up zu
mutieren
das wäre es gibt es die frage auch nicht
von schickh friends kommt nicht mehr die
spritze rein jagen lassen würde ob ich
es plane und ich kann dir sagen lieber
schick friends sobald ich dran bin und
sobald ich einen termin bekommen kann
werde ich mich impfen lassen und dann
bin ich auch tatsächlich absolut nicht
wählerisch welchen impfstoffe ich
bekomme hauptsache ich bin gegen diese
verdammte krankheit irgendwann mal
besser geschützt als ich jetzt jetzt bin
aber hier gab es auch die frage an sie
herr doktor specht weiter oben das finde
ich jetzt nicht mehr weil sie gesagt
haben es wäre nicht ihr lieblings
impfstoff astrazeneca von texten würden
sie denn bevorzugen
ich würde tatsächlich ein ma im stoff
bevorzugen ich bin ganz ehrlich das ist
ja ein ganz neues prinzip da wissen wir
vielleicht auch noch nicht alles
allerdings zeigt dass ich doch dass der
impfstoff eine gute moderner ginge
genauso oder wahrscheinlich dann auch
für weg wenn er dann zugelassen wird
weil er eine gute immunantwort macht
weil er offensichtlich in der lage ist
auch tatsächlich das weitergeben der
infektion später zu verhindern wenn ich
also games bin und weil er tatsächlich
eine relativ niedrige immunreaktion bzw
im und nebenwirkungen von der impfung
macht das finde ich ganz elegant ich
kenne aber auch in meinem kreis umkreis
ärztliche kollegen die inzwischen schon
geimpft sind mit moderner zum teil die
anderen mit biotech und da gibt es
solche und solche die haben wenig
gemerkt und andere hatten doch auch ganz
heftige impfreaktionen also ich glaube
dass die die muss man einfach einkaufen
die sind dann eben da die würde ich auch
einkaufen ich würde mir jetzt nicht ein
marathon für die tage nach der impfung
vornehmen
okay da sozusagen schon gehört man
sollte sich lieber mal da wochenende
freinehmen oder zwei tage einplanen dass
man da vielleicht eher nur fernseh
gucken kann wenn überhaupt da ich das
habe ich dann gerade noch ich hatte noch
einen schönen spruch hier gerade genau
von martin schäfer ich halts beim
hemmstoff wie beim bier lieber astra als
kuchen haben wir auch noch werbung für
biersorten untergebracht natürlich noch
ganz viele andere tolle wir sollten aber
der paste jetzt ganz gut ich habe hier
gerade
eine
nachrichtenagentur meldung bekommen herr
doktor specht und zwar hat sich bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder dafür
ausgesprochen den acht weniger sind
impfstoff selbst wenn es jetzt zu
einschränkungen kommen würde und die
europäische arzneimittelagentur sagen
würde lieber nicht wir müssen noch
weiter schauen oder nur unter bestimmten
umständen dafür plädiert also er
plädiert dafür dass man den trotzdem auf
eigenes risiko quasi sich weiter
spritzen lassen kann wäre das eine auch
für sie aus medizinischen
gesichtspunkten vertretbare lösung also
ich habe das auch gehört live also dass
gerade sagte da dachte ich schon das
wird aber ein spaß für die juristen
etwas kann ich mir nicht vorstellen also
wenn die ehemals sagt und damit ja
letztendlich tatsächlich die bedingte
zulassung dieser impfstoff jahr hat wie
die anderen übrigens außen alles
bedingte zulassung also für ein jahr
wenn die jetzt sagen würden wir nehmen
diese zulassung zurück dann gibt es ja
interessante haftungsfragen und einfach
sich vorzustellen
ich glaube da macht es ja so etwas
einfach dass der impflinge wie das so
schön heißt also derjenige der geimpft
werden möchte sagt ich nehme das auf
meine eigene kappe
das könnte juristisch spannend werden ob
das überhaupt möglich ist also das wäre
eine schlechte idee entweder muss die
immer sagen wir haben überhaupt keine
einschränkung wir bleiben beim
bisherigen verfahren oder sie sagt
ver.di und die patientengruppen oder
menschengruppen altersgruppen männer
frauen was auch immer pille anamnese
thrombose oder was auch immer
mit dieser einschränkung lassen den
weiter zu das müssen sie schon sagen
wenn sie tatsächlich nein sagen würden
dann würde ich mich daran halten
es gibt sie noch mehr ich sehe gerade
her doch verspricht noch mehr bier
sprüche ich habe es beim impfstoff auch
beim impfstoff auch wie beim biermann
journale soll endlich wieder im
öffentlichen raum verteilt werden
hier gab es aber auch durchaus ernst
gemeinte fragen von fremden zum beispiel
1 darüber wachen sollte man sich
überhaupt astrazeneca impfen lassen denn
es mit biom biotech und moderner
hochwertigere impfstoffe gibt gibt es
das überhaupt so etwas wie einen
hochwertigeren impfstoff ich glaube dass
man das nicht sagen kann dass die
rechnung wer mal am ende machen
wenn wir dann wirklich sehen welche
impfstoffe welche wirkungen und
nebenwirkungen gehabt haben dafür ist es
noch ein bisschen früh bei und tech ist
ein super impfstoff technisch gesehen
deswegen weil er so geschickt gebaut ist
weil man ihn so wunderbar anpassen kann
und das wird übrigens nötig seien in den
nächsten jahren ich denke wir werden bei
montech 20 30 40 und so weiter auch von
den anderen stoffen sehen weil das virus
sich eben auch anpasst verändert das
geht bei so einem erna im stoff
natürlich sehr viel leichter innerhalb
von sechs wochen kriegen das hin
produziert werden es braucht aber nicht
nochmal eine neue komplette zulassung
zumindest sollte man davon ausgehen
dürfen dass ist ja noch ein relativ
neues verfahren aber es wird sozusagen
nur der kopf wie bei einem werkzeug nur
der kopf oben eben verändert das ist
schon schick aber dass ich jetzt sagen
würde das ist der hochwertige impfstoff
so und will ich nicht gehen
so jetzt gibt es ja noch mal ein paar
wortmeldungen zu der frage kann ich mich
auf mein eigenes risiko hin impfen
lassen oder nicht muss noch mal kurz
schauen wo habe ich es gesehen da naja
willi meint aber wenn ich mich doch
selber impfen lassen möchte ist das doch
meine sache darunter die wortmeldung von
anja bei eigenem risiko sinkt die
akzeptanz doch noch mehr so vielleicht
können sie das noch mal ein bisschen
genauer erklären warum kann ich nicht
einfach sagen ich nehme ich auf meine
kappe oder schreibt da was dass ich das
wollte und dann ist gut ich mache mal im
vergleich wenn wir auch sonst eine
therapie haben vielleicht bei einem
patienten der wirklich erkrankt ist und
vielleicht auch lebensgefährlich
erkrankt ist und gibt es eine nicht
zugelassene therapie aber die gibt es
halt und der arzt meint dass er das
nicht verantworten kann der patient sagt
aber ich will das auf meinen risiko dann
hatte ein problem weil ich habe zwar den
anspruch als patient sagen zu können
oder das recht sagen zu können ich
möchte die und die therapie nicht ich
möchte überhaupt keine therapie ich gehe
da gar nicht hin ich entlasse mich
selber all das ist in meiner
verantwortung als mensch ich bin herr
meiner selbst da kann ein arzt anordnen
was er will das danach ich sowieso mehr
beim anordnen der kann vielleicht seinen
wieder erweitern was anordnen aber aber
nicht den patienten gegenüber andersrum
kann aber der patient nicht einfordern
ich will jetzt geimpft werden dass das
geht einfach nicht wenn es eine
ärztliche leistung ist in dem fall ist
es das da gibt es ein arzt vorbehalt
dafür dann muss ich den arzt finden der
das dann auch macht und mit der haftung
ist das so die juristen das wäre er eine
juristische frage aber die juristen
sehen das ziemlich also schauen dass
sich genau an ob es überhaupt möglich
ist diese haftung so komplett von sich
wegzuschieben und zu sagen ja der
patient zu patient herz ja gewollt
aufklärung ist natürlich nötig aber wenn
es eine nicht zugelassene therapie ist
muss ich erstmal den arzt finden der das
dann auch macht jetzt habe ich jetzt
eben leider auch mal wieder leute die
komplett in frage zu stellen ob ein
corona menschen versterben das sind
nicht bei mittlerweile 70 tausend toten
und jeden tag kommen leute dazu bisschen
schwierig die frage geht also an uns ob
wir persönlich menschen kennen die
anwohner gestorben sind ich kenne
persönlichen menschen die menschen
kennen die an corinna gestorben sind und
ich glaube das sollte reichen und ich
finde auch diese diskussion muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen
ein jahr nach ausbruch der pandemie also
schon mehr als einem jahr nach ausbruch
der pandemie und ein jahr nach feier des
ersten lockdown echt müßig so ich schaue
mal weiter es gab hier noch ein paar
fragen also erst mal lob für sie von
ramona dieser mich erleichtert die
einordnung von ihnen herr doktor specht
denken sie dass der entschluss auch zur
wiederaufnahme der impfung und
astrazeneca in anderen europäischen
ländern führen würde
das ist doch auch hier drin oder
interessante frage
ja man muss ja sagen die anderen länder
waren ja vor der emea und haben gesagt
wir verknüpfen den jetzt erstmal nicht
in deutschland hat gesagt das urteil der
ema ist für uns bindend
die anderen könnten theoretisch
entscheiden was wir wollen aber es hätte
natürlich eine signalwirkung wie ja auch
die whu aussage eine signalwirkung für
die gesamte welt handeln dann ist auch
eine interessante frage hier von c3
nicht die erste priorität ist es ja die
schweren verläufe zu verhindern wurde
einmal geprüft ob es vielleicht sinnvoll
wäre mehr leuten zunächst eine halbe
oder eine viertel dosis zu geben
eher unfreiwillig wurde das getan
astrazeneca war ja geplant als einmal
impfung sowie jetzt übrigens der neue
johnson johnson im stoff astrazeneca
hatte nie vor eine vector impfung zu
machen mit zwei impfstoffen also mit
zwei impfterminen das ist übrigens der
grund warum die den gleichen weg tor
genommen haben für die impfung 1 und für
die impfung 2 was medizinisch
biologische ich so richtig sinnvoll ist
aber die haben dann eben gesehen dass
nach der ersten impfung der impfschutz
nicht so doll ist wie sie das erwartet
hätten anders als bei johnson johnson da
war ein bisschen höher
sputnik übrigens ist ja auch so ein
vector im shop die haben von anfang an
gesagt wir machen das mit zwei impfungen
und bei astrazeneca war jetzt folgendes
passiert ein fehler tatsächlich ein
versehen eine subgruppe der population
der der studienpopulation wurde nur mit
der halben dosis geimpft mit der bei der
bei ersten impfung
normalerweise hätte man jetzt sagen
müssen so die probanden muss ich leider
rausschmeißen weil die daten kann ich
nicht weiter verfolgen das passt ja
nicht zum studienprotokoll das wollte
man aber nicht hat die drin gelassen und
hat dann denen danach beim zweiten
termin die volle dosis gegeben und dann
stellte sich auch noch zu allem
überfluss heraus dass die effektivität
bei dieser subgruppe besser war als bei
denen die zwei mal die volle dosis
bekommen haben biologisch lässt sich das
auch ganz gut erklären wegen dieser
desgleichen sektors bei der ersten und
zweiten impfung aber nur ganz
interessant da hat man also schon
gesehen was mit einer halben dosis ist
ich glaube nicht dass man hier gehen
kann und sagt so wir sparen jetzt ein
bisschen unternehmen sah man überall nur
die hälfte der dosis dann müsste man
doch davon ausgehen dass die
immunantwort nicht reicht vor allen
dingen bei denen die am haupt die am
meisten gefährdet sind nämlich die
älteren muss man sich nur vorstellen das
immunsystem altert mit uns menschen mit
wir alle haben wenn wir mal 60 70 80
sind nicht mehr das tolle immunsystem
die mit 20 und das bedeutet auch dass
die impfungen nicht so gut angehen wie
wir es gerne hätten sehen wir bei der
grippeimpfung jedes jahr
trotzdem ist es da noch besser überhaupt
einen impfschutz zu haben als gar kein
so jetzt gibt es ja noch an der
wortmeldung von kevin 18 die die oder
der meint mit eurem interviews schafft
ihr es leider schon wieder dass die
ängstlichen leute sich noch weniger mit
astra impfen lassen möchten das hoffe
ich
ist nicht der fall wir haben ja immer
wieder darauf hingewiesen sagte specht
hat darauf hingewiesen dass das eine
persönliche risiko abwägung ist das gibt
ein ries
bei diesen impfstoff wie bei jedem
impfstoff also es gibt quasi keinen
impfstoff der komplett risikofrei ist es
gibt keine medizin die risikofrei ist es
ist aber noch unbewiesen ob es
tatsächlich einen zusammenhang gibt
zwischen diesen impfstoff und diesen
thrombosen die aufgetreten sind und
tatsächlich haben wir auch darauf
hingewiesen
wir machen jeden tag viele handlungen
und nehmen viele medikamente die alle
nehmen wird man risiken risiken haben
von daher hoffe ich dass wir jetzt hier
tatsächlich wieder also wieder abwickeln
wollen und irgendwie leute in falscher
sicherheit wiegen möchten noch dass wir
menschen zu viel angst einjagen wir sind
hier um das zu versuchen besser
einzuordnen so eine letzte frage noch an
sie doktor specht bevor ich mich gleich
an meinen kollegen stefan leifert in
brüssel unterhalte
was ist der unterschied vom sputnik
impfstoff zu den anderen das habe ich
mich tatsächlich auch immer wieder
gefragt also warum gibt es
unterschiedliche vector impfstoffe weil
das ist ja die selbe medizinische
technologie die dahinter steckt was
machen die verschiedenen
arzneimittelhersteller anders oder wie
sind die anders aufgebaut ist doch immer
dasselbe virus
nein das sind verschiedene viren das
sind immer verschiedene vehikel
adenoviren war es weniger wie gesagt war
als einmal impfung geplant da hat man
gedacht wir nehmen ein vehikel ein
adenovirus was beim menschen sicher noch
nicht vorgekommen ist nämlich einen
schimpansen erkältungsvirus das macht
bei menschen nichts aus aber es ist ein
schönes vehikel das war die idee wenn
man es eben nur einmal für impfen müsste
jetzt klappte das mit dem einmal nicht
so gut man sah dass man zweimal impfen
muss und hat jetzt die zweite impfdosis
eben auch mit dem gleichen impfstoff
genommen was dazu führt dass manche
menschen dann aber auf das läuft die
erste impfung auf sind adenovirus nach
den sektor auch schon antikörper
gebildet haben sputnik hat auch
adenoviren hat aber von anfang an gesagt
wir machen zwei impfungen wusste also da
kommt eine zweite danach und hat dann
gesagt
dann nehmen wir zwei verschiedene lkws
also für die erste impfung da steht auch
darauf erste impfung und für die zweite
impfung und anderen an den rektor damit
eben die antikörper da nicht
durcheinanderkommen also antikörper die
nach der ersten impfung schon gebildet
worden sind das ist ein großer
unterschied zwischen sputnik und
astrazeneca und hinzu kommt es sind
andere ag noweck tor während diese
beiden die sputnik verwendet für die
ersten und findet zweite impfung das
sind adenoviren die beim menschen sehr
wohl ab und zu vorkommen deswegen dachte
ich eigentlich am anfang das wäre nicht
so klug dieses konzept aber weil es eben
dann auch da schon antikörper geben
könnte aber offensichtlich spielt das
nicht so die große rolle
das konzept ist also durchaus valide und
gut allerdings weil die frage auch immer
wieder aufkommt darum haben wir jetzt
nicht einfach sputnik zugelassen das
läuft ja die schauen sich das ja sehr
genau an ich weiß auch dass der firma
astrazeneca hat durchaus mit sputnik
gespräche geführt weil die idee ist ob
man da vielleicht eine impfung nachsetzt
sozusagen mit einer sputnik lösung wenn
der zugelassen ist und wenn der richtig
untersucht worden ist dann spricht auch
nichts gegen sputnik aber diese
zulassung die würde ich selber schon
gerne abwarten wollen so wir haben zwar
noch einige fragen an sie herr doktor
specht aber ich würde jetzt trotzdem
einen kleinen break machen weil wir
schon relativ lange reden aber ich freue
mich dass immer mehr leute in stream
sind also sagt auch gern bescheid wir
warten hier darauf dass sich die
pressekonferenz in brüssel von der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur mal
bewegt die haben die ganze tk von 16 uhr
auf 17 uhr verschoben
wir bleiben trotzdem erstmal darauf
verließ sie es gibt auch sehr viel
gesprächsbedarf sehr viele fragen die
uns der doktor specht netterweise
beantworten konnte ich würde ihnen jetzt
mal eine viertelstunde break können herr
doktor specht und würde mich freuen wenn
wir dann so gegen viertel vor fünf
wochen miteinander reden können
das ungefähr 17 uhr bis die pk losgeht
weil ich habe hier noch ein paar fragen
für sie die ich auch gerne beantworten
würde aber jetzt würde ich erst mal zu
meinem kollegen stefan leifert schalten
der nicht in brüssel ist wie ich gerade
gesagt habe sondern in amsterdam bei der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur man
weiß bei euch bei der brüsseler team
immer nicht so ganz genau wo er sei
straßburg brüssel amsterdam ist immer da
unterwegs du stehst vor der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur nämlich an und
wartet darauf dass sie sich bewegen hast
du raus zu kommen warum das so lange
dauert oder warum sie die
pressekonferenz verschoben haben
weil die sitzung immer noch andauert das
findet jetzt nicht hier hinter mir im
gebäude statt oder hier hinter mir und
gebäude zumindest nur teilweise das
ganze ist eine video-konferenz und die
läuft jetzt schon seit geraumer zeit es
sollte eigentlich wie du gesagt hast und
16 uhr eine pressekonferenz geben dann
ist es auch 16 uhr 30 verschoben worden
jetzt ist es inzwischen schon 17 uhr
zusammen geschaltet ist dabei ein
ausschuss der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur dieser ausschuss ist
dafür da risiken von arzneimitteln zu
bewerten und die beschäftigen sich jetzt
eben gerade mit der alles entscheidenden
frage zu astrazeneca
der vorgang war der dass in den letzten
tagen und stunden immer wieder neues
datenmaterial hier nach amsterdam
geliefert worden ist was jetzt
ausgewertet wurde in den letzten naja
sagen wir mal zwei tagen vor allem dass
soldaten gewesen über die vorfälle in
den einzelnen ländern von blutgerinnseln
in deutschland in belgien in frankreich
in großbritannien und dieser ausschuss
versucht jetzt in der kürze der zeit vor
allem die eine frage zu beantworten gibt
es eine ursächlichkeit gibt es eine
kausalität zwischen diesen aufgetretenen
blutgerinnseln auf der einen seite und
der impfung mit astrazeneca auf der
anderen seite und wenn diese frage
bejaht wird wenn es eine kausalität gibt
dann ist die zweite frage wie groß ist
denn das risiko wie groß ist die häufung
wie viele fälle haben wir haben wir
jetzt gesehen und wie können wir das
dann in die zukunft prognostizieren und
auf dieser grundlage muss die immer dann
eine entscheidung oder zumindest eine
empfehlung abgeben wie es mit den
impfungen mit astrazeneca in europa
weitergeht aber können wir davon
ausgehen dass wenn wir die
pressekonferenz sich verschiebt wenn
diese sitzung weiter andauert das ist da
doch uneinigkeiten in dieser in diesem
expertengremium gibt das ist ja
zumindest immer der fall wenn wir auf
die ergebnisse der presse konnte also
der ministerpräsidenten konferenz mit
der bundesregierung warten je länger es
dauert desto größer ist der streit
das wäre spekulation aber ich glaube
dass es eine gewisse incidents dafür
gibt dass es dass es so ist dieser
ausschuss der markt eher versucht
allerdings immer mit zu entscheiden das
ist ja in vielen europäischen
entscheidungsgremien so dass man
möglichst immer mit einstimmigkeit
entscheiden will
er müsste es nicht er könnte auch eine
mehrheitsentscheidung treffen aber bei
so weitreichenden entscheidungen wie
jetzt hier über die verwendung von
arzneimitteln wird schon versucht einen
konsens herzustellen
die zweite möglichkeit oder die zweite
ursache für diese verzögerung und den
streit könnte aber auch sein dass das
datenmaterial einfach nicht eindeutig
genug ist und die frage einfach zu
komplex ist um sie in dieser kürze der
zeit zu entscheiden es gibt deswegen
manche die darüber spekulieren ob die
möglicherweise die entscheidung noch
einmal verschiebt sie hat ja auch am
dienstag schon sich öffentlich zu wort
gemeldet und gesagt es sei noch zu früh
zu entscheiden dann hat man den
donnerstag genommen als termin also
jetzt besteht auch eine gewisse
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die er heute
noch einmal sagt uns reicht das
datenmaterial nicht mehr verschieben die
entscheidung noch einmal um ein paar
tage vielleicht mal zur einordnung also
was ist dir eigentlich ganz genau und
welche wir wichtigkeit hat das veto
dieses dieses gremiums dann auch für die
kommission und im endeffekt auch für die
europäischen länder könnten sich der
einzelnen länder auch hinstellen und
sagen schön liebe eu-kommission was sie
jetzt meint wimmer wir machen das
trotzdem nicht oder wir machen es
trotzdem doch
möglich wäre dass die kernaufgabe der
ehemals die zulassung von arzneimitteln
und diese zulassung für den impfstoff
astrazeneca dies ja im januar erteilt
worden und dass die jetzt komplett
zurückgenommen wird das ist eher
unwahrscheinlich möglich wäre das auch
aber darauf deutet eigentlich nichts hin
alles was darüber hinaus geht das sind
empfehlungen das was hier heute
stattfindet das ist nur eine riise das
heißt nur also das ist eine sehr
wichtige risikobewertung und auf der
grundlage wird eine empfehlung
ausgesprochen aber die länder müssen
sich nicht daran halten das ziel ist
schon dass die eu einheitlich
entscheidet damit nicht am ende die
situation auftritt dass frankreich
beispielsweise weiter in deutschland
aber nicht aber theoretisch wäre das
möglich und dass das gar nicht so außer
reichweite ist das zeigt auch der
heutige tag für ein paar stunden hat
sich der bayerische ministerpräsident
zum beispiel geäußert und hat gesagt
egal was die ema entscheidet er sei fest
entschlossen in bayern weiter mit astrid
astrazeneca impfen zu lassen also
möglich wäre das gewünscht ist
allerdings möglichst große
einheitlichkeit innerhalb der eu länder
da haben wir auch gerade schon mit
doktor specht drüber gesprochen und
sondern die zehn journalisten und
experten der das ganze kritisch gesehen
hat er meinte das ist juristisch gar
nicht so einfach dass man einfach
durchzuziehen trotzdem bleibt ist eine
spannende diskussion
vielleicht nur ein kurzer überblick
lieber stefan die viele europäische
länder haben dass es tatsächlich das
impfen ausgesetzt und welche haben es
nicht getan also das ist ja doch wieder
ja im endeffekt der flickenteppich den
wir auch mit unseren ganzen maßnahmen in
deutschland haben wo es in verschiedenen
bundesländern unterschiedlich aussieht
wie sieht es jetzt auf europäischer
ebene aus mit diesen stoffen
auf europäischer ebene hat die große
mehrheit der länder das impfen mit
astrazeneca eingestellt weit mehr als
die hälfte und darunter sind vor allem
auch die großen mitgliedsländer also
frankreich deutschland beispielsweise
belgien zum beispiel hat entschieden
weiterzumachen
abhängig davon oder entscheidend für
diese frage war in vielen ländern
natürlich wie groß ist der anteil von
astrazeneca als impfstoff in diesem mix
alle länder haben ja einen leicht
unterschiedlichen images die einen haben
mehr bayon tag und weniger astrazeneca
bei den anderen ist es umgekehrt diese
entscheidung die ist ja im laufe des
letzten jahres schon gefallen als man
nicht genau wusste welcher impfstoff
eigentlich das rennen macht als man auch
noch nicht genau wusste welcher
impfstoff ist eigentlich wie wirksam
was man damals als einziges wusste ist
wie teuer ist welcher impfstoff und auf
der grundlage haben manche länder in
osteuropa bulgarien zum beispiel oder
kroatien sehr viel von astrazeneca und
vielleicht aus heutiger sicht ein
bisschen zu wenig von bayern tag
bestellt und das schlägt heute natürlich
dann zurück zu bekommen jetzt ein paar
fragen wir hatten soeben auch schon die
fragen nach den russischen impfstoff
nach sputnik wie jetzt gibt es hier die
frage von kennern nach dem impfstoff aus
china warum wird er bei uns nicht
geimpft also gibt es da schon
bestrebungen in der emea auch diese ein
stoffe aus russland und aus china
zuzulassen oder sich genauer anzuschauen
sputnik schaut sich die europäische
arzneimittelagentur an nichts ist im
moment so politisch wie im stoff und das
gilt natürlich dann für diese beiden
impfstoffe erst recht aber da jetzt die
not so groß ist und der mangel an
impfstoff in der eu so groß ist versucht
man das jetzt so politisch neutral oder
so entpolitisiert wie möglich sich
anzuschauen die ema prüft das und man
hört jetzt inzwischen aus immer mehr
mitgliedsländern dass man wenn die ema
eine freigabe gibt für den impfstoff
also sputnik zum beispiel dass man dann
auch bereit sei damit zu impfen damit
die impfkampagne der europäischen union
endlich fahrt aufnimmt
könnt ihr das ganze dann tatsächlich
auch zu einem spielball zwischen den
verschiedenen mächten werden dass dann
russland sagt ja
er bekommt das aber nur wenn wir zum
beispiel ich sage mal hypothetisch mit
unserer gaspipeline weitermachen dürfen
da gibt es ja auch einen großen streit
also ist es möglich dass es tatsächlich
jetzt so eine art druckmittel wird auch
von der regierung putin
das würde in der europäischen union
natürlich jeder weit von sich weisen und
so plump oder so direkt würde das
natürlich auch nicht gespielt werden
aber natürlich würde putin das auch als
machtinstrument nutzen und vor allem als
kleines zeichen des triumphs seinerseits
und der russischen wissenschaft nutzen
um die eu an dieser stelle vorzuführen
aber es würde sicherlich kein so plump a
deal eingefädelt werden eben stoff gegen
gegen gaspipeline aber natürlich die im
finger gegenüber den impfstoff aus
russland sind in der europäischen union
natürlich aus all diesen gründen etwas
länger als bei impfstoffen die
beispielsweise in der europäischen union
hergestellt werden so für alle die jetzt
erst dazu gekommen sind wir versuchen
immer noch oder wir warten immer noch
auf die pressekonferenz der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur die von 16 auf 17
uhr verschoben wurde eigentlich hätte
sie jetzt schon durch sein können aber
es scheint da doch etwas länger zu
dauern bis sich die systeme um einig
wird wir haben schon mit dr christoph
specht medizinjournalist oder viele
fragen gesprochen die sich zu diesen
ganzen komplexen ergeben gerade sprechen
stefan leifert unserem brüsseler
korrespondenten der genau vor der em
gerade steht in amsterdam
ich würde sagen für alle die jetzt
vielleicht auch nicht so richtig wissen
was letzten wochen oder letzten tage
passiert ist gucken das noch mal den
überblick amt von hannibal was mit
diesem astrazeneca impfstoff eigentlich
war es ging so gut los
die ankündigung im august vergangenen
jahres astrazeneca will die eu mit 400
millionen dosen beliefern doch schon die
erste lieferung macht probleme
der pharmakonzern hat
lieferschwierigkeiten die eu bekommt
deutlich weniger als erwartet
gleichzeitig verunsichern meldungen über
die wirksamkeit bei on tagfalter und
moderner habe
eine wirksamkeit von über 90 prozent
astrazeneca etwa 60 prozent
und dann auch noch das kurz vor der
zulassung empfiehlt die ständige
impfkommission astrazeneca nur für
menschen bis 64 jahren die zulassung
kommt trotzdem am 30 januar diesen
jahres im februar schon ist klar gegen
die südafrikanische virus mutation
schützt der impfstoff nur begrenzt
geimpft wird weiter irgendwann auch an
ältere menschen bis vor wenigen tagen
dänemark stoppt die impfung als erstes
weitere eu länder folgen schließlich
auch deutschland die impfung könnte in
zusammenhang mit hirn thrombosen stehen
solang noch mal die frage an unseren
brüssel korrespondenten stefan leifert
kannst du noch mal ganz kurz
zusammenfassen für alle die gerade erst
dazu geschaltet haben oder erst noch
nicht so lange dabei sind was
entscheidet denn es wollte die
europäische arzneimittelagentur nach den
vorfällen von blutgerinnseln in den
letzten tagen muss die ema heute
entscheiden wie es weitergeht mit der
impfung des impfstoffes astrazeneca
angesichts der blutgerinnsel dies in
vielen fällen gegeben hat möglich sind
drei verschiedene szenario erstens eine
verschiebung de man könnte sagen uns
reicht das datenmaterial noch nicht wir
müssen länger prüfen und nehmen uns noch
mal mehr zeit für die entscheidung
das zweite szenario ist dass die ema
keine empfehlung ausspricht so wie
bisher weiter zu impfen mit astrazeneca
und die dritte möglichkeit und ich
glaube das ist die wahrscheinlichste ist
die dass die ihre immer die empfehlung
ausspricht zwar weiter zu impfen mit
astrazeneca aber mit der einschränkung
bestimmte risikogruppen von der impfung
auszunehmen also patienten mit
vorerkrankungen patienten mit
gerinnungsprozess mit blutgerinnung das
problem das könnte so eine entscheidung
sein oder eine war noch weitreichende
einschränkung wäre zum beispiel dass man
eine ganz große gruppe von der impfung
aus nimmt also frauen unter 50 das wurde
auch spekuliert ist im moment aber
glaube ich nicht das wahrscheinliche
szenario
stefan dann vielen dank wir warten
darauf was die ema heute beschließt sie
nun losgehen
ich denke erst mal nach amsterdam später
bis später und dann schalte ich wieder
zurück zu unserem medizinjournalist und
experten dr christoph specht herrscht
echte wir haben hier fragen ich würde
sagen holen sie sich popcorn und ein
café das kann länger tanz also ich weiß
sie haben auch nicht mehr so viel zeit
und wir wollen ja auch gemeinsam noch
die pressekonferenz anschauen sie sind
heute ein sehr gefragter
gesprächspartner deswegen freue mich
dass wir trotzdem doch relativ viel zeit
mit ihnen hier haben ich fange jetzt mal
hier an bei den fragen die wir haben
also einmal eine kritische frage uns
wurde wieder vorgeworfen wir würden
bestimmte sachen nicht ansprechen und
verschweigen dass es mitnichten der fall
es geht nämlich um die sterblichkeit
also hier gab es eine wortmeldung die
hat gesagt es sind 1,6 millionen
impfungen erfolgt und stand heute sind
entweder 13 menschen schwerst erkrankt
oder gestorben
da wird schon wir das vermischt also
schwerst erkrankt und gestorben sind
zwei verschiedene sachen aber diese
behauptung also ist das risiko eines zu
123.000 ich ergänzt mal dass das
schlimmes passiert ist das tatsächlich
der fall also das datenmaterial habe ich
nicht was jetzt zuschauer den zuschauern
da hat dieser könnte man ja ausrechnen
band die zahlen ebenso sind aber noch
einmal es ist immer ein abwägen zwischen
nutzen und risiko wovon wir sicher nicht
reden ist von einem großen risiko das
können wir schon sagen weil das hätten
wir gesehen bei 17 millionen impfdosen
astrazeneca die vererbt worden sind
denken sie england england wie die
weltmeister da haben wir die ganze zeit
hingeguckt mit dem finger auf die
regierung gezeigt dass sie machen alles
falsch die enge name ist alles richtig
gemacht der israelis dann auch ja dazu
gehört aber dann auch dass man eben auch
wirklich impfen haben die natürlich auch
mehr impfstoff aber wenn da solche
dramatischen zahlen aufgetaucht werden
glauben sie mir das hätten wir gemerkt
also von daher es ist kein nullrisiko
und genau das sagen wir ja eben auch es
gibt kein nullrisiko wie hoch das risiko
ist dass ist bisher in zahlen nicht
exakt zu beziffern allerdings wenn es
ein solches risiko gibt das können wir
schon sagen ist es kein großes risiko
auch die frage schließt sich direkt an
von hubert müller der uns geschrieben
hat ich glaube per mail in
großbritannien sind ja schon millionen
menschen mit astrazeneca geimpft worden
wie sind denn dort die entsprechenden
zahlen in sachen blutgerinnseln im hirn
ja das ist sehr interessant da gibt es
diese zahlen seltsamerweise nicht oder
auch nicht seltsamerweise woran das
liegen mag
es kann zum beispiel sein das ist jetzt
aber auch nur eine überlegung in england
wurden ja auch von anfang an ältere
menschen vor allen dingen ältere
menschen geimpft mit gerade mit dem
astra zeneca impfstoff und
möglicherweise ist es so dass dieses
geringe risiko einer sinus
venenthrombose sich eher bei jungen
menschen darstellt und vielleicht auch
gerade eben so wie wir es gesehen haben
das war ja diese zahl 6 + 16 frauen ein
mann bei weiblichen menschen also frauen
und wenn das so ist dann könnte das sich
schon erklären dass wenn die
antibabypille möglicherweise auch eine
rolle spielt wie gesagt alle
spekulationen können wir jetzt alles
nicht sagen
dann wäre es verständlich dass bei den
älteren die in england wie gesagt die
importe sind das weniger oft aufgetreten
ist deutlich weniger oft so jetzt haben
wir ganz viele fragen von mehreren
zuschauer innen zum thema ja was ist
denn wenn ich schon geimpft wurde also
steffi folgt schreibt wenn der impfstoff
komplett vom markt genommen werden würde
wie wird damit den leuten verfahren die
die erste impfung von astrazeneca schon
erhalten haben werden die von grund auf
neu immunisiert selbe frage von max haut
und dann die anschlussfrage von florian
thiel kann ich mich denn dann mit einem
anderen impfstoff impfen lassen sollte
die zweite dosis quasi nicht mehr zur
verfügung stehen wie sieht das dann
daraus also wenn es nur einen shot
gegeben hat bislang ja also was
verhaftet es ist für uns
selbstverständlich und es ist ja nicht
so dass dann kein impfschutz bestehen
würde es noch nicht ausreichend bis
jetzt ist es so stand heute dass ein
impfstoff mix nicht zugelassen ist also
ich kann nicht astrazeneca und dann
biotech oder umgekehrt oder moderner mit
bayern technischen all das ist eben
nicht untersucht da gibt es keine
datenlage deswegen gibt es dafür keine
zulassung
es erfolgen momentan gerade solche
studien und es ist auch schon passiert
glaube gerade heute wieder aus versehen
dass menschen erst mit biotech und dann
mit astrazeneca ich glaube so maaß
geimpft worden sind da ist auch nichts
passiert aber wie gesagt das sind keine
wissenschaftlichen studien sollte es
durch so sein dass astrazeneca nicht
mehr als zwei zusagen zur verfügung
steht dann wird man darf eine lösung
finden
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass man erst
mal dann nicht impft eine längere pause
ist sowieso bei astrazeneca er
effektiver als eine zu kurze pause und
dann wird man hoffentlich studiendaten
haben dass man sagen kann ja man im
stand mit biotech oder mit johnson
johnson oder was auch immer was dann als
zweiter im stoff dazu kommt so jetzt
gibt es hier noch andere fragen zum
beispiel mit der ansteckung von sehr
spannend auf youtube wie sieht es damit
anstecken aus kann die impfung die
ansteckungsgefahr herunterfahren
ich nehme an es ist gemeint damit dass
ob ich als geimpfter mich erstmal
überhaupt noch infizieren kann und wenn
ich dann infiziert bin ob ich das einem
anderen übergeben kann so sagt euch
einen anderen ansteigen kann ich nehme
an dass das gemeint ist also nach den
daten die bis jetzt vorliegen gerade
auch aus israel sieht es so aus dass
zumindest die bei und tech impfung bei
astra sind aber auch solche daten schon
tatsächlich die gefahr einer infektion
nach der impfung zumindest in der ersten
zeit in den ersten monaten wie lange das
ist kann man natürlich noch nicht sagen
aber vermutlich ist ein halbes jahr auf
jeden fall deutlich reduziert ist und
damit natürlich wenn ich selber nicht
infiziert bin kann ich natürlich auch
einen anderen nicht infizieren
und dann gibt es ja noch die zweite
möglichkeit dass man sich vielleicht
doch infizieren könnte und dann aber
trotzdem nicht infektiös ist weil
möglicherweise die virus menge ebenso
gering ist dass es nicht reicht ein
jemand anderes anzustecken auch dafür
gibt es hinweise
gerade heute haben wir gehört in einer
studie bei astrazeneca das gilt aber für
die anderen impfstoffe mit sicherheit
ähnlich dass ältere nicht so gut vor
einer kita ansteckung geschützt sind wie
jüngere menschen das gilt aber auch für
die durchgemacht die infektion nicht in
der ersten zeit für die ersten monate
dürfte das kein problem sein aber was
danach zwei drei vier jahren ist damals
anders aussehen aber das ist keine
überraschung das haben wir bei allen
anderen erkältungsviren anderen
erkrankungen ja auch das immunsystem
arbeitet sehr effektiv das schaut sich
an oder ist ein virus der machen wir es
mal antikörper gegen und dann seht ihr
am anfang auch schnell wieder gebildet
sollte dass wir es noch mal auftauchen
aber wenn das ewig nicht auftaucht also
viele monate jahre
sagt das immunsystem auch okay scheint
nicht mehr vor zu kommen da müssen wir
auch nicht mehr viel vorhalten also
lassen sie das mal kostet nur energie
und dann kann man sich eben auch wieder
anstecken
so jetzt ist auch die frage genau was
passiert später sie haben ja schon
gesagt also später wissen wir nicht wie
das aussieht florian ahlmer möchte
wissen wie es eine eventuelle spätfolgen
ausschauen könnte
ich mag es mal die man wegen der schnell
zulassungen jetzt und heute noch nicht
absehen kann ich habe eben noch
kommentare gelesen diese richtung gehen
normalerweise wird ein impfstoff fünf
bis zehn jahre getestet und erst dann
weiß man bescheid das ist hier alles
viel zu schnell gegangen was können sie
denn dazu sagen also das ist jetzt schon
wieder fremming und wurden schnell zu
lassen es hat keine schnelle zulassung
gegeben was richtig ist dass die zeit
der zulassung kürzer war indem man diese
studienphasen zusammengeschoben hat
diese vision realität ist nicht gleich
schnell zu lassen
da würde ich einen unterschied machen
weil das klingt so nach dem motto wir
schauen mal nicht so genau hin es
reichen uns auch die hälfte der studien
probanden oder mangan schnellen haken
hinter so war das nicht sondern man hat
nur die studienphasen die normalerweise
sequenziell hintereinander ablaufen
zusammengeschoben und die prüfung hat
schon stattgefunden als die unterlagen
erst noch eingereicht wurden das ist
sonst nicht der fall sonst ist es wie
bei einer klassenarbeit da sagt mama do
kosten ich die ersten kapitel schon
abgeben ich möchte bitte die ganze
diplomarbeit oder was es haben wenn du
fertig bist und nicht einzelne kapitel
das hat natürlich die zeit etwas
beschleunigt aber auch noch zum thema
langzeitfolgen dahinter steht ja die
vorstellung da könnte doch was sein wie
bei medikamenten zum beispiel wenn ich
das im jahr nehme passiert vielleicht
noch nicht aber nach 34 jahren ein name
dann könnte es sich vielleicht irgendwas
entwickeln bei impfstoffen ist das
anders wenn sich da etwas unangenehmes
entwickelten das gibt es ja immer wieder
ich denke an pandemrix zb damals diese
sogenannte schlafkrankheit bei der
ersten schweinegrippen impfung dann ist
das etwas was sehr schnell in den ersten
tagen manchmal sogar stunden wochen
maximal vielleicht 12 monaten auftritt
etwas anderes ist und das stimmt es
dauert häufig bis man den zusammenhang
erkennt also eine ein schaden wenn er
den auftritt tritt relativ schnell auch
auf aber wenn das eben etwa
ist was entweder häufig ist häufig auch
bei anderen fällen vorkommen was mit der
impfung gar nichts zu tun hat oder eben
hin zu sehr sehr geringen anzahl
auftritt dann ist es manchmal schwer
diese zusammenhänge zu sehen und das
kann in der tat ein bisschen dauern bis
man dann herausgefunden hat das hängt
mit dem also in dem fall dann der
impfung zusammen es gibt sogar die frage
wir haben über das mögliche risiko von
schweren nebenwirkungen gesprochen oder
vielleicht auch von todesfällen die
ganze wortmeldung kam von vino blanchot
sie haben dann gesagt ich weiß nicht auf
welche zahlen sich dieser user bezieht
und da gab es dass die kritik da sollte
man doch schon auf dem schirm haben als
eingeladener experte dann müssen wir
einfach sagen lieber oder liebe vino
blanco wenn du mit diesen zahlen hier
ankommst dann bitten wir auch um eine
quelle
weil das ist immer schnell geschrieben
so und so viele menschen ist das und das
passiert aber das müssen wir tatsächlich
dann nochmal nachprüfen weil da gibt es
ja auch fragezeichen ob es tatsächlich
im zusammenhang mit der impfung zu
todesfällen gekommen ist das ist selbst
bei diesen hirn thrombosen bislang noch
nicht bewiesen und das lässt sich auch
nicht so schnell und einfach beweisen
nur weil eine impfung erfolgt ist und
danach jemand stirbt muss das nicht
immer miteinander zusammenhängen so wir
haben noch sechs minuten bis vielleicht
die pressekonferenz der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur losgeht bislang habe
ich noch nichts gegenteiliges gehört
ich schaue noch mal also wir hatten hier
noch einige fragen an sie doktor specht
genau ich hatte hier eine frage verträgt
sich die pille mit dem impfstoff von
anna lena meyer
das wissen wir nicht genau also wenn es
so ist dass die impfung tatsächlich das
thromboserisiko in seltenen fällen aber
eben in diesen seltenen fällen erhöht
dann wäre anzunehmen dass die einnahme
der pille vor allen dingen solche mit
einem erhöhten thromboserisiko das ist
auch nicht bei allen fällen gleich und
möglicherweise noch anderen
risikofaktoren kontraindiziert ist das
könnte sein dass das thema entscheidet
dass so was rauskommt wie etwa frauen
mit gleichzeitiger einnahme der
antibabypille sollten die impfungen
nicht bekommt das könnte sein aber das
wissen wir nicht was wo ohne die wohin
die frage erzielt ist wir reden hier
über thrombosen und jeder hat schon mal
gehört die anti baby pille ist zumindest
manche mit einem erhöhten
thromboserisiko verbunden und das stimmt
auch vor allen dingen dann wenn rauchen
dazu kommt und übergewicht immobilität
also was weiß ich durch die krankheit
zum beispiel wenn diese faktoren
zusammenkommen dann kann man fast sagen
ist eine thrombose fast schon eingekauft
das passiert dann leider sehr auf das
risiko ist sicher sehr viel höher
das muss ja nicht immer gleich tödlich
sein aber das ist natürlich eine
gefährliche leben gekommen so jetzt gibt
es hier die frage von rave mehr wenden
gerade bei astrazeneca bei jüngeren im
klingen wie dass er tatsächlich heißt im
fliegen also jemand dagegen für das ein
instinkt hat ein schönes wort
wir stehen da immer einen sehr kleinen
menschen bevor der irgendwie ein
bisschen rundlich aussieht wie ein
findling beispiel aber tatsächlich sind
ja alle im fliegen sobald wir eine
spritze bekommen also wenn gerade bei
jüngeren menschen es zu komplikationen
gekommen sein könnte muss man ja immer
hypothetisch sagen gibt es die frage von
rave mehr warum nicht ältere menschen
mit astra impfen also 65plus und jüngere
stattdessen mit moderner kaiser
das könnte das könnte sich so ergeben
durchaus vielleicht wird das so wissen
wir nicht kann der ema nicht vorgreifen
weil ich die daten die die ema hat
natürlich nicht habe
das könnte aber an einen ein ergebnis
sein gedacht hatte man es natürlich
nicht zurückgesandt weil ich manche
leute ja wie kann das denn sein erst
hieß es doch älteren nicht mit
astrazeneca impfen und wenn es dann
eines tages heissen würde doch gerade
die älteren impfen da muss man natürlich
sehen wie ist das gekommen die älteren
nicht von metastasen garten ja nicht
gesagt wenn man daten gehabt hätte das
wirkt da nicht oder es ist gefährlich
sondern macht es eben genau gesagt weil
man eben keine daten über ältere hat nur
12 4 prozent der studienteilnehmer bei
dieser astrazeneca studie waren älter
als 55 jahre
und das ist einfach ein bisschen dünn um
daraus dann ablesen zu können wie
effektiv ist eigentlich der impfstoff
deswegen hatte man entschieden auch die
stiko also die ständige impfkommission
hier wissen wir nicht genug also lassen
wir erst mal die ab 65 jährigen raus
andere länder haben anders entschieden
england hat eben gleich geimpft und wir
haben sie inzwischen also die stiko hat
es dann auch verändert dahingehend aber
natürlich wissenschaft ist beweglich es
kann sein dass eines tages die
empfehlungen lauten wird vielleicht wie
gesagt die junge frauen bei
gleichzeitiger einnahme anti baby pille
nicht mit astrazeneca ist denkbar
noch ist es viel zu früh das zu sagen so
ich habe jetzt die 2 kommentare und dann
sind wir vielleicht auch mal 17 uhr wenn
sie noch beantworten zwei fragen
das eine ist die behauptung es gibt doch
gar keine zulassung von kyoto 66 die ist
nur vorläufig auf ein jahr begrenzt
anmerkung auch eine begrenzte zulassung
dass eine zulassung
die hersteller haben zeit bis ende 2023
die fehlenden daten einzureichen das
habe ich so noch nicht gehört aber ich
bin auch nicht der experte dafür
deswegen gebe ich die frage an unseren
experten weiter januar spricht ist das
sogar richtig
das ist eine begrenzte zulassung genau
das ist so und die gilt für ein jahr und
da müssen daten nachgeliefert werden
dass bei all diesen impfstoffen zu euch
kennen gar keinen der anders jetzt
zugelassen worden wäre völlig normal
bestimmt ja das heißt kann man da jetzt
ist es ein grund mehr skepsis zu haben
gegenüber diesen impfstoffen oder was
kann man jetzt kann ich wüsste nicht
warum nur ist es eben so man man hat
eben die zulassung als bedingte
zulassung ausgesprochen das heißt man
kann diesen impfstoff verwenden aber das
unternehmen der unternehmer der
pharmazeutischen unternehmer muss
weiterhin daten liefern das heißt nicht
nur altdaten sondern eben auch neue
daten die jetzt in dieser zeit entstehen
und das geschieht ja dauernd weil das
wären ja neue daten erfasst studien
laufen ja weiter auch die zum beispiel
der der erste mensch der mit bayern
check oder astrazeneca verhängt worden
ist oder geimpft worden ist
auch die werden ja alle weiter
beobachtet man guckt sich das ja an und
diese daten fließen dann eben damit
hinein würde sich da irgend etwas zeigen
dann würde die immer eben sagen wir
nehmen die zulassung zurück oder würden
sie verändern zurücknehmen ist eher
selten aber verändern wie das vielleicht
jetzt bei astrazeneca ist das kann es
schon geben das gibt es bei anderen
medikamenten auch so und jetzt höre ich
hier doktor specht und sehe es auch hier
auf meinem vorschlag monitor
dass die pressekonferenz der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur in den
startlöchern steht
drücken wir mal kurz gucken wie das
aussieht so sieht es da aus das heißt da
wird es in wenigen minuten losgehen wenn
sie ganz pünktlich sind wäre jetzt noch
eine minute zeit und um 17 uhr würden
sie anfangen
ich würde sagen wir schalten jetzt mal
einfach auf dieses signal und herren
zusammen der dinge
es ist ja schön guten tag und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem virtuellen
pressebriefing unser sicherheitskomitee
hat heute seine besprechung der seltenen
fälle von blutgerinnseln bei patienten
besprochen und während dieses presse
briefings möchten wir ihnen sagen was
der ausschuss besprochen hat und was die
nächsten schritte sind
ich heiße marianne halbe und bin
vorsitzende der presseabteilung und wir
haben es hier bei mir exekutivdirektorin
der ema dr sabine strauß vorsätze des
sicherheitsausschusses des
pharmakovigilanz ausschusses und ich
freue mich auch ihnen peter ahnert
vorzustellen der der analytik bei der
ema vor steht der ihnen zusätzliche
infos geben kann zu den wesentlichen
fragen bevor wir anfangen möchte ich
ihnen kurz erläutern wie wir dieses
pressebriefing gestalten möchten ihr
mikro ist zunächst mal deaktiviert wir
werden erstmal dr strauß und immer cook
das wort erteilen und danach haben wir
30 minuten auch zeit für fragen
wenn sie da fragen stellen möchten dann
bitten wir sie die hand zu heben
dann müssten sie dann auf das icon neben
der teilnehmerliste dann bitte drücken
das heutige briefing wird über satellit
übertragen und alle medien können
kostenlos zugreifen oft diese
pressekonferenz die einladung ist
gestern ausgegangen ich erteile jetzt
immer guckt das wort ja herzlichen dank
und schönen guten nachmittag
vielen dank dass sie sich eingewählt
haben zu diesem pressebriefing unser
expertenausschuss der pharmakovigilanz
committee hat die fälle von
blutgerinnseln von menschen analysiert
die mit dem astra zeneca wachsen geimpft
wurden und die klare wissenschaftliche
schlussfolgerung ist dass dies ein
sicherlich sicheres und wirksames
produktes dass menschen vor corona
schützt wobei die nutzen deutlich über
den risiken liegen
das vakzin ist auch nicht zu assoziieren
mit einem erhöhten risiko eine
entwicklung von hirn venenthrombosen
während der prüfung haben wir
festgestellt dass es eine kleine anzahl
seltener aber sehr schwer wegen der
tromm politische entwicklungen gab
blutgerinnsel die sich bildeten nach
tagen detaillierter analysen analysen
von labor analysen können wir nicht
ausschließen dass es eine verbindung
zwischen diesen fällen und dem vakzin
gab deswegen empfiehlt der ausschuss
eine bewusstseins schärfung für die
möglichen risiken um sicherzustellen
dass sie auch in den
produktinformationen aufgelistet sind
die menschen darauf hinzuweisen dass es
diese risiken gibt so
kann man mögliche nebenwirkungen
aufdecken und mitregieren
wir werden auch weitere analysen auf den
weg bringen um diese seltenen fälle
besser zu eruieren und so gezielte
evaluierungs studien auf den weg zu
bringen über sieben millionen menschen
über 17 millionen wurden in unter sieben
millionen wurden in der europäischen
union geimpft mit diesen aktien über 17
millionen in großbritannien
es ist wichtig dass alle nebenwirkungen
engmaschig überwacht werden um sicher zu
gehen dass wir mögliche risiken erfassen
und die menschen darüber informieren dr
strauss wird im detail schildern was die
bewertung war des ausschusses aber
unsere einschätzung ist dass eine
sichere option bietet um die bürgerinnen
und bürger gegen korona zu schützen
eine 60 prozentige wirksamkeit ist
nachgewiesen
bei dem schutz gegen korona und die
evidenz könnte so geriert dass die
wirksamkeit noch höher sein könnte wir
wissen dass einige mitgliedstaaten die
impfung des vakzins suspendiert haben
und warten auf unsere empfehlung aber
tagtäglich sterben tausende von menschen
in der europäischen union über 2500
waren es an einem tag in der letzten
woche deswegen war es wichtig für die eu
so schnell wie möglich die zur verfügung
stehenden daten zu prüfen deswegen haben
unsere experten intensiv daran
gearbeitet im detail alle verfügbaren
daten zu analysieren
wir haben die europäischen exporten im
bereich thrombose und blut störungen
auch involviert bei der prüfung und
haben mit anderen gesundheitsbehörden
zusammen gearbeitet auch der britischen
die wissenschaftliche schlussfolgerung
bietet der mitgliedstaaten die nötigen
informationen um eine informierte
entscheidung zur nutzung des astra bett
in den clubs ins in der impfkampagne zu
fällen bevor ich dr strauß das wort
erteilen
ich möchte ich hervorheben dass die
situation wie die die wir gerade hier
festgestellt haben nicht unerwartet ist
wenn man millionen von menschen impft
ist es unvermeidbar dass seltenen
krankheiten auftreten können direkt nach
der impfung unsere rolle im
regulatorischen system der europäischen
union ist diese vorfälle schnell
aufzudecken wo zu überprüfen ob sie
möglicherweise im zusammenhang mit der
impfung stellen oder nicht
wir sind verpflichtet sicherzustellen
dass irgendwelche adversen reaktion
schnell geprüft werden um so
wissenschaftliche prüfungen anzustellen
um das vertrauen in die impfung
wiederherzustellen das so wichtig ist um
diese schreckliche pandemie in den griff
zu bekommen
die schlussfolgerung die wir heute
ziehen wird uns helfen den kampf gegen
die pandemie fortzusetzen indem wir
bewusstsein schärfen betreiben und
aktuelle informationen zur verfügung
stellen sobald neue informationen zur
verfügung stehen so dass die systeme in
europa wissen was sie tun müssen
vielen dank vielen dank frau guckt jetzt
erteile ich dr strauß das wort
herzlichen dank der firma q villages
ausschuss dem ich vorstehe hat sich im
detail die fälle von blutgerinnseln
angeschaut die nach einer verpuffung mit
dem astra zeneca impfstoff aufgetreten
sind sobald diese besorgnis aufgetreten
ist letzte woche hat der ausschuss eine
umfassende analyse alle indikationen
angestoßen und hat alle belege
angeschaut die uns vorlagen ich möchte
den belgischen team danken dass mit
kollegen der nationalen behörden und
auch der europäischen
arzneimittelbehörde zusammengearbeitet
hat zusammen auch mit fachkräften die
sich im bereich blut störungen auskennen
die schlussfolgerung ist dies ist ein
sicheres sichere impfstoff zur
vorbeugung gegen korona und die vorteile
überwiegen die risiken
wir haben keinerlei nachweis dafür
gefunden dass es qualitäts bedenken gibt
der ausschuss hat präklinische und
klinische studien angeschaut die
veröffentlichte literatur und auch
reaktionen zu denen es kam während der
impfkampagne unerwünschte ereignisse die
uns vorgelegt wurden eine kritische
analyse wurde angestellt und eine
klinische analyse der einzelfälle die
uns aus den einzelnen mitgliedstaaten
signalisiert wurden wurde angestellt die
trombone
die herren venenthrombosen die auftraten
waren weniger in den fällen als in der
population und wir können somit
schlussfolgern dass dieses im dass
dieser impfstoff eine hohe wirksamkeit
hat und wird somit wahrscheinlich die
das risiko thrombotische ereignisse
insgesamt reduzieren
es gibt aber noch eine gewisse
unsicherheit wir haben einige sehr
seltene fälle berichtet bekommt wo eine
kombination aus thrombose und
thrombozytopenie beschrieben wurde in
wenigen fällen hatten sich kleine
gerinnsel in mehreren blutgefäßen
entwickelt 7 bis 14 tage nach der eben
von disseminierten intramuskuläre
koordination ist der fachbegriff wir
haben auch festgestellt dass es
gerinnsel gab die sich in blutgefäßen im
hirn gab die so genannte sinus
venenthrombose die sich entwickelt hat
diese bedingungen hängt damit zusammen
dass es eine geringe anzahl von
blutplättchen gibt und die nachweise die
wir derzeit haben sind nicht ausreichend
um zu sagen ob diese unerwünschten
ereignisse mit dem vakzin zusammenhängen
oder nicht deswegen wird unser ausschuss
weitere zusätzliche studien durchführen
und überwachen
wir haben auch geschlussfolgert dass es
wichtig ist dass zu sagen dass diese
unerwünschten ereignisse sehr selten
sind sieben fälle diese fälle gab es 18
fälle der sinus wien thrombose bei fast
insgesamt 20 millionen geimpften
personen
bei den großen klinischer studien kam es
nicht zu solchen fällen das zeigt aber
wie wichtig es ist wachsam zu sein
sobald ein vakzin einer breiten
bevölkerung zugänglich gemacht wird
wir haben auch gesagt wie wichtig es ist
dass die fachkräfte im gesundheitswesen
und auch die menschen die sich impfen
lassen wissen welche unerwünschten
ereignisse es geben kann damit man
wachsam ist wenn es irgend welche
symptome gibt die sich nach der impfung
zeigen
deswegen haben wir die empfehlung das in
cleveland eine beschreibung dieser
unerwünschten ereignisse gibt so dass
die bevölkerung sich darüber informieren
kann wir werden sicherstellen dass die
healthcare professionals und auch die
bevölkerung diese informationen somit
nachlesen kann weiß welche nebenwirkung
es geben kann
damit man auch rechtzeitig reagieren
kann wenn irgendwelche symptome nach
einer verpuffung auftreten könnten
vielen dank dass strauß wenn sie
irgendwelche fragen haben haben sie
jetzt die möglichkeit dazu wenn sie eine
frage stellen möchten dann müssten sie
bitte das handzeichen aktivieren
in der web apps konferenz und wenn sie
dann das wort erhalten müssen sie sich
an minuten sie können uns dann sagen wie
sie heißen und für wen sie arbeiten
schauen wir ob es irgendwelche fragen
gibt
bislang sich niemand gibt es
irgendwelche fragen
gabriel sunny hat eine frage gabriele
bitte würden sie ihre frage stellen wenn
sie bitte auch ihre kamera dann
einschalten
gabriel hat seine ich arbeite in italien
glauben sie dass die anwendung des
prinzips der vorsicht von mehreren
staaten wie italien deutschland jetzt
dazu führt dass das vertrauen der
bevölkerung in das astra zenica
endprodukt mindert vielleicht kein frog
diese frage beantworten ja herzlichen
dank für diese frage viele
mitgliedsstaaten warten jetzt auf das
ergebnis unserer sicherheit überprüfen
und sie haben uns auch gesagt dass das
was die ema wissenschaftlich betrachtet
gemacht hat sehr wichtig sein wird damit
die mitgliedstaaten dann entscheiden
werden wie sie weitermachen mit der
impfkampagne und wir liefern heute und
es ging darum sicherzustellen dass
bekräftigt wird dass der nutzen höher
ist als das risiko damit den
mitgliedstaaten ein informierte
entscheidung treffen können und dass das
vertrauen in den impfstoff erhöhen kann
susi ring aus von bloomberg ist die
nächste ja hallo gab es eine verbindung
zwischen den fällen und dem impfstoff
und sie sagten dass es jetzt ein update
gibt auf dem label aber update also es
wird eine aktualisierung der inter
kennzeichnung aus den
produktinformation geben dr trausch
drauf kann dazu was sagen ja wir haben
gesagt dass es einen vorschlag gibt das
4.4 das produkt zusammenfassung
aktualisiert werden sollte und auch dass
patienten lief mit dem beipackzettel
also aber das ist natürlich eine ganz
besondere situation deswegen diskutiert
der ausschuss jetzt gerade auch wie man
mit der allgemeinheit sprechen könnte
und auch einhält skelett ein schreiben
was man üblicherweise an healthcare
professionals in ganz europa aus schickt
damit die hälfte für fashion los diese
zusätzlichen informationen dann
nachlesen können und somit einen hilfe
an die hand bekommen um risiken zu
minimieren wenn patienten solche zeichen
oder symptome dann entwickeln und wir
möchten auch dass die geimpften gewissen
welche signale welche symptome eben zu
beachten sind für den fall dass es
irgendwelche entwicklung von
blutgerinnseln bei ihnen gäbe
jetzt würde ich tom clark von itv das
wort erteilen bitte tom tom können sie
uns hören wir können sie sehen aber wir
hören sie nicht vielleicht ist ihr
mikrofon noch ausgeschaltet
gut wir können leider nicht hören dann
geben wir erst einem anderen kollegen
das wort so ban
bitte sehr
also da gibt es anscheinend auch ein
problem mit der verbindung so wir können
sie auch nicht hören wir sehen sie zwar
aber wir hören sie nicht so können sie
nochmal versuchen ihre frage zu stellen
wir hören sie leider nicht
können sie uns den höheren und scheint
gibt es hier ein problem mit der
verbindung tut mir sehr leid
viele journalisten haben wir gerade
signalisiert dass sie uns auch nicht
mehr hören können
es sieht so aus dass viele journalisten
uns leider gar nicht hören können
es tut uns sehr leid liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wir versuchen das problem
hier zu prüfen
haben sie denn hören können was wir
überhaupt ausgeführt haben denn es kam
mir zumindest die ersten fragen genau
ich denke schon denn es kam ja auch
fragen und es würde uns ja auch
sicherlich jemand gesagt haben wenn man
uns überhaupt nicht gehört hätte und es
kam mir auch die ersten fragen versuchen
wir mal ob roland der motor vom standard
uns hört können sie uns hören und können
sie ihre frage stellen
ja ich kann sie hören und ich hoffe sie
können mich auch da die verbindung
unterbrochen wurde deswegen weiß ich
jetzt nicht ob die frage von jemand
anders bereits gestellt wurde sie haben
wir gesagt dass der nachweis den sie
haben nicht ausreicht um zu sagen ob
diese art wersen effekt jetzt diese
unerwünschten ereignisse von dem
impfstoff ausgelöst werden könnte es
denn von was anderem ausgelöst sein und
welche anderen szenarien prüfen sie in
bezug auf faktoren die diese ereignisse
hätten auslösen können
vielleicht kann dr strauß antworten
herzlichen dank
wir haben unterschiedlichste hypothesen
besprochen wie ihm zu schauen welche
erklärung ist geben könnte für diese
fälle wie wir wissen es corona selbst
ein wichtiger risikofaktor für
thrombosen und auch post cupid syndromen
führen dazu dass menschen oft mit
thrombosen ins krankenhaus kommen
thrombosen in der aorta das könnte also
auch eine rolle gespielt haben aber
derzeit haben wir den eindruck das ist
ausreichend informationen gibt um eine
fahrinformation in die
produktinformation aufzunehmen wir
werden das weiter prüfen mit unserem
scientific advisory group mit den
wissenschaftlichen beratern da gibt es
weitere studien geben und vielleicht
möchte mein kollege dann auch was dazu
sagen welche weiteren studien will eben
auf den weg bringen werden um ein
definitiver antwort dann herbeizuführen
peter möchten sie noch was hinzufügen
herzlichen dank
das ist in der tat eine wichtige
sicherheitsprüfung wir müssen
sicherstellen dass die
sicherheitsprüfung fortgesetzt wird und
dass wir von der wissenschaft hier
getrieben sind dass wir eine schnelle
und robuste prüfung erhalten eine
weitere prüfung wird auch zusätzliche
sachverständigen ratschläge zu nutzen
und auch epidemiologische studien wo wir
also health care daten aus der echten
welt dann nutzen um uns so anzuschauen
wie viele thrombose fälle es gab er dann
auch labortests nutzen um zu schauen ob
diese patienten die eben diese
unüblichen gerinnsel entwickeln
vielleicht etwas besonderes gemeinsam
haben etwas auszeichnet vielen dank für
diese zusätzlichen informationen dr alle
jenny hill von der bbc hat um das wort
gebeten jenny bitte sehr
ja hallo aus ihren prüfungen in dieses
seltenen ereignisse gibt's da
irgendeinen hinweis der zeigt dass
spezifische gruppen einem höheren risiko
einer thrombose entwicklung ausgesetzt
sein könnten
ja die überprüfung der fälle von
thrombosen hat gezeigt dass es bei
einigen gruppen ein höheres risiko gab
insbesondere bei frauen und bei jüngeren
menschen bei jüngeren frauen es ist aber
noch zu früh um jetzt hier eine
schlussfolgerung zu einer bestimmten
gruppe zu schließen denn das hintergrund
risiko einer thrombose könnt ihr dieser
gruppe auch unterschiedlich sein
es könnte aber auch der fall sein dass
mehr menschen bereits geimpft wurden in
dieser spezifischen gruppe so dass man
hier zum beispiel dann deswegen zu
dieser überzahl an jungen frauen
gekommen ist und ich weiß dass es in den
unterschiedlichen mitgliedstaaten
verschiedene
impfkampagnen gab und wenn es hier
risikominimierung optionen gibt dann
werden wir sie dann natürlich in
kenntnis setzen
ohne alexander sauer von der post in
norwegen hat es um das wort gebeten
hitze ja ich heiße ohne alexander aus
norwegen
wie bewerten sie denn das dem bericht
der osloer universität
haben sie diesen bericht auch schon
bedacht dr strauß wir haben alles
geprüft was bis gestern zur verfügung
stand denn wir hatten natürlich
unterschiedliche berichte die wir
geprüft haben wenn heute also noch ein
neuer bericht wieder lanciert wurde dann
haben wir den nicht prüfen können aber
wir haben die fälle analysiert die uns
vorgelegt wurden auch aus norwegen und
die haben wir im detail revue passieren
lassen und geprüft und es gibt auch
einen norwegischen vertreter bei unserem
pharmakovigilanz risk assessment
committee von daher alles geprüft was
wir aus norwegen bekamen aber wenn es
ein bericht gab der gerade heute noch
veröffentlicht wurde so haben wir den
nicht geprüft aber es wird eine
kontinuierliche weitere überwachung
dieser themen geben und wir werden diese
themen wird eben schon gesagt sowieso
ständig weiter prüfen das ist jetzt nur
eine vision schlussfolgerung auf der
grundlage der von uns vorgelegten fälle
aber es wird auf jeden fall in zukunft
also geprüft tom clark von itv wir haben
sie vorher nicht gehört wir hoffen
könnte wenn es jetzt hören
vielen dank dass ich jetzt noch mal das
wort bekomme sie haben gesagt dass sie
18 fälle hatten und dann noch eine
andere anzahl mit einem anderen phänomen
also einerseits haben sie die sinus wenn
thrombose erwähnt und dann noch ein
anderes ereignis was ich nicht so
richtig verstanden
bei uns in großbritannien gab es ja nur
fünf fälle von bst obwohl wir doppelt so
viele dosen von astrazeneca bereits
verimpft haben
dr strauß los angeles killer corporation
das ist ein syndrom hus praktisch zu
einer thrombose kommt einem
blutgerinnsel wo gleichzeitig die
thrombozyten in ihrer anzahl gesenkt
werden das heißt man hat eine thrombose
gleichzeitig mit einem einer blutung
das ist also eine weitere erklärung
dieses spezifischen erkrankung und
derzeit ist es recht schwierig genau die
gründe zu kennen warum es einen
unterschied in den fällen gibt
wir haben jetzt auf der grundlage
spontan berichtet der fälle gearbeitet
und was wir auf jeden fall sicher wissen
ist dass die menschen die geimpft wurden
sehr unterschiedliche gruppen waren auch
zwischen einerseits den mitgliedstaaten
der eu und der und dem vereinigten
königreich das könnte eine erklärung
sein
aber derzeit sind wir noch nicht sicher
wie man das erklären kann dass es in
großbritannien weniger fälle gab als in
den mitgliedsstaaten der eu
also ich würde spekulieren die
wahrscheinlichste erklärung ist dass
unterschiedliche patienten gruppen
geimpft wurden in großbritannien wurden
insbesondere ältere menschen geimpft und
im vergleich zu den anderen
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
war dass sie anders und wenn also
blutgerinnsel stärker bei jüngeren
frauen zum beispiel auftreten dann würde
ich denken dass
deswegen logisch ist dass es mehr fälle
in den mitgliedstaaten der europäischen
union gab als in großbritannien
jetzt bekommt rico schmitt das wort
bitte vielen dank
könnten sie die fälle von solibro sie
vielleicht noch mal genauer beschreiben
und erklären was dort gerade gesagt
wurde das wort hatte am anfang aber guck
das ist die direktorin der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur sie hat gesagt
astrazeneca der impfstoff ist ein sicher
wirkende sex wachsen damit meinte sie
dass also dieses wachsen dieser
impfstoff sicher vor einer corona
infektion schützt dass es wirkt oder vor
einer schweren vor einem schweren
verlauf schützt aber sie können nicht
ausschließen dass ist das risiko von
hirntumoren tatsächlich gibt wenn auch
selten
weitere analysen wie die ema jetzt auf
den weg bringen und das ganze auch
engmaschig überwachen damit risiken
sichtbar werden aber die ganz klare
einschätzung der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur der wirkstoff von
astrazeneca bietet eine sichere option
um die bürgerinnen vor corinna zu
schützen das heißt die zulassungen wird
nicht zurückgenommen es wird keine
weiteren einschränkungen geben darüber
war im vorhinein spekuliert worden ob
zum beispiel ist die empfehlung gibt
dass bestimmte personengruppen mit
diesem stoff nicht geimpft werden
sollten aber das ist jetzt tatsächlich
nicht der fall die europäische
arzneimittelagentur hat entschlossen
oder hat bekannt gegeben der nutzen
dieses impfstoffes ist größer als das
risiko dass das geben könnte die
mitgliedstaaten können jetzt auf
grundlage dieser informationen
entscheiden ob sie erst weiter nutzen
oder das haben sie zumindest
verklausuliert so gesagt die situation
ist aber auch nicht unerwartet meinte
biskup wie wenn man millionen von
menschen impft sei es unvermeidbar dass
seltene krankheiten auftreten können
diese vorfälle müssten schnell
aufgedeckt werden und die ema muss
prüfen ob sie im zusammenhang mit der
impfung stehen und dann gab es noch die
ergänzung von sabines tross aber vom
pharmakologischen risikoabschätzung
komitee so habe ich es mal über
der gesagt mögliche nebenwirkungen die
es da geben kann sollen jetzt in die
beipackzettel aufgenommen werden also
quasi in dieses große diese große
mögliche nebenwirkungen aufzählungen
damit sich die bürger dort informieren
können so und jetzt möchte ich über
dieses ergebnis mit doktor christ dorf
spinner sprechen ich hoffe er ist da vom
klinikum rechts an der erich der isel so
heißt es in münchen
ich grüße sie schön dass sie spontan für
uns zeit hatten sie sind oberarzt
pandemie beauftragter und infektiologe
jetzt haben sie gerade wahrscheinlich
mitverfolgt was die ema dort bekannt
gegeben hat sind sie mit dieser
einschätzung einverstanden
hallo ich grüße sie ich glaube was wir
heute gesehen haben ist vor allem aus
meiner sicht eine hoffnungsvolle
nachricht denn sie zeigt auch dass die
prüfmechanismen die wir auch bei
zugelassenen arzneimitteln und
impfstoffen in deutschland und europa
zur anwendung bringen funktionieren
das heißt auf die signale die das
paul-ehrlich-institut der beobachtet
hatte wurden umgehend mit den
europäischen partnern weitere analysen
veranlasst und ich glaube wie die immer
eben schön zusammengefasst hat gibt sich
derzeit keinen hinweis dafür dass
weniger impfstoff nicht sicher ist
natürlich lässt sich gerade bei den sehr
seltenen möglichen nebenwirkungen nie
mit abschließender sicherheit klären ob
dies im zusammenhang mit dem impfstoff
stehen oder nicht und der jetzt
eingeschlagene weg noch genauer
hinzuschauen ist habe ich auch aus
meiner sicht der absolut richtige weg
den sicherheit von arzneimitteln muss er
im vordergrund stehen und das gilt
natürlich auch für impfstoffe aber
trotzdem landes ein bisschen so dass die
ema sich irgendwie nicht ganz sicher ist
ob es tatsächlich einen zusammenhang
gibt es zwischen diesen aufgetretenen
hin thrombosen und der impfung sehen sie
das auch so verstanden oder auch so
gedeutet
also ich glaube die frage lässt sich an
dieser stelle einfach nur sehr schwer
abschließend klären denn
wie in den ende weise konferenz eben
schön ausgeführt wurde hängt es am ende
natürlich auch davon ab wie viele
menschen werden von welcher
populationsgröße sprechen wir also
werden vor allem ältere menschen oder
vor allem jüngere frauen eher ein
höheres risiko dieser sehr seltenen
sinus venenthrombosen also die sehr
seltenen besonderen thrombosen der
hirnversorgenden gefäße haben und all
diese faktoren spielen eben mit hinein
in die häufigkeit dieser seltenen
erkrankungen um jetzt wirklich die
kausalität klären zu können in jedem
einzelfall thema und die zuständigen
behörden diese einzelfälle so gut und so
genau wie möglich betrachtet aber gerade
weil diese komplikationen so selten sind
ist es auch so schwierig die
ursächlichkeit zu klären und mit letzter
sicherheit lässt sich die ursache heute
eben nicht wirklich zurückführen
und ich glaube deshalb auch die
entscheidung in summe überwegs die
sicherheit dieses arzneimittel soll
dieses impfstoffes nach wie vor bei
weitem
weitere analysen sollen dabei sehr
aufmerksam darauf achten ob sich
zukünftige sicherheits signale
bestätigen oder vielleicht doch wieder
legen wenn mehr menschen geimpft werden
denn so geht es uns mit allen
arzneimitteln und medizinischen
prozeduren je mehr erfahrung damit
vorhanden ist desto genauer kann auch
eine einschätzung gelingen so jetzt
schaue ich mal bei uns in die kommentare
da gibt es einerseits ja freude darüber
dass es wohl weiterhin eine also dass es
weiterhin eine zulassung geht von der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur wir
warten jetzt auch darauf was
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
dazu sagt auch er hat eine
pressekonferenz angekündigt gleich im
anschluss ich gucke mal ob für das bild
schon haben tatsächlich also da sehen
wir ein bislang leeres pult im
bundesgesundheitsministerium aber das
ganze ist schon aufgebaut das heißt das
kann jederzeit losgehen dass jens spahn
vor die kameras tritt und sich dann auch
äußert was er dann sagen wird da sind
sehr gespannt aber man kann ja fast
davon ausgehen
dr spinner dass die impfung mit
astrazeneca in deutschland wieder
aufgenommen wird oder
ja das würde ich hoffen denn ich glaube
die gute nachricht des tages ist auch
dass ich dieses vom
paul-ehrlich-institut jetzt erstmals
gefundene sicherheit signal dieser
seltenen sinus venenthrombosen nicht in
großen bestätigen ließ oder vielmehr ist
keine hinweise darauf gab dass
ernsthafte sicherheitsbedenken gegen
dieses arzneimittel vorlegen wir hatten
eben darüber gesprochen mit letzter
sicherheit lässt sich nicht klären ob es
vielleicht doch einen zusammenhang gibt
aber gerade auch in der größenordnung
wie diese möglichen nebenwirkungen
diskutiert wurden sind sie nach wie vor
sehr sehr selten und dem stoff bieten
uns auch dass astrazeneca vakzin
zuverlässigen schutz vor schweren
kurbelt bedingter krankenhausaufnahme
und tod und darauf kommt es natürlich
gerade in der zeit steigender
infektionszahlen ganz entscheidend an so
ich schaue mal ob es sie jetzt fragen zu
dieser entscheidung gibt das ist ja doch
also sie wurde lange erwartet teilweise
gibt es hier jetzt stimmen die sich hier
die das ganze skeptisch sehen
morgen gibt's noch ein ins gipfel da
wird weiter entschieden das hatte
zumindest hier wir uns daran erinnert
stimmt der ist ja auch verschoben worden
dieser impfgipfel aber dann auch immer
wieder diese stimmen das ist auch zum
teil an experiment können sie diese
einschätzung teilen die wasserspinne ich
glaube wir sprechen nicht von einem
experiment sondern der astrazeneca
impfstoff ist durch reguläre
zulassungsprüfungen gegangen das heißt
er hat alle notwendigen arzneimitteln es
studien erfolgreich durchlaufen und es
gab in den arzneimittelstudien keine
hinweise auf ein ungünstiges risiko
nutzen verhältnis das gilt natürlich
auch ein mittel
ganz ohne risiko ist aber was sich
erfreulicherweise nicht bestätigt hat
ist dass es in größerem ausmaß hinweise
auf thrombotische ereignisse also
hinweise auf gesteigerte blutgerinnung
neigung des astra zeneca impfstoffes
gibt zumindest zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
und ich will an dieser stelle auch noch
mal daran erinnern andere länder hatten
ja bereits letzte woche die eben
gestoppt beide zur diskussion standbein
venenthrombosen oder andere
thrombotische komplikationen vielleicht
im zusammenhang mit dem hilfsstoff
auftreten auch das hat sich heute nicht
bestätigt also die immer hat
zusammengefasst die vorteile des
impfstoffes überwiegen die nachteile bei
weitem und die diskutierte komplikation
mit den sinus venenthrombosen besprachen
der von 7 oder jetzt acht fällen in 1,6
millionen menschen ist dennoch sehr sehr
selten und gerade weil die erkrankung so
selten ist ist sie auch schwierig eine
ursache zuzuordnen
ich gab es auch gerade stimmen die
darauf verwiesen haye bei der
antibabypille bei der hormonellen
verhütung da gibt es sehr viel mehr
fälle von thrombosen das sind das keine
hin thrombosen trotzdem tritt diese
nebenwirkungen auf das wird da wird nie
darüber gesprochen also das ist ist das
tatsächlich eine unterschätzte
nebenwirkung die wir an einfach
hinnehmen weil uns daran gewöhnt haben
also ich möchte vielleicht noch einmal
hervorheben weil sich eingangs schon
gesagt habe wir kein arzneimittel und
auch keine impfstoffs gänzlich frei von
risiken es gibt jetzt in den letzten
tagen sehr viel diskussion darüber dass
auch andere arzneimittel mit einem
erhöhten risiko von thrombosen
ereignissen vor allem an venenthrombosen
und so genannten lungenarterien embolien
einhergehen können das gilt unter
anderem für die anti baby pille die das
risiko im vergleich zur
normalbevölkerung ungefähr vervierfacht
aber auch beispielsweise übergewicht für
2,78 etwa den faktor thrombotische
erkrankungen zu erkranken
und dieser thromben bullischen
eigentlichen die beinvenenthrombose
genannt der in der politik immer mal ein
vielfaches häufiger sie kommen nämlich
ungefähr in jedem tausendsten mensch in
deutschland pro jahr vor
man kann sie dennoch nicht mit den jetzt
diskutierten sinus venenthrombosen
vergleichen
die entstehungsmechanismen sind zum teil
völlig unterschiedlich aber um das noch
einmal zusammenzufassen aus meiner sicht
wenn ich es ein positives signal dass
die sicherheitsmechanismen
auch zugelassene arzneimittel und
impfstoffe in europa gut und auch
schnell funktionieren denn die meldung
über diese sinus venenthrombosen am
montag wird bereits heute also vier tage
später von einer ausführlichen
sicherheitsuntersuchung der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur beantwortet und ich
glaube das sind gute nachrichten auch in
der pandemie die sicherheitsmechanismen
funktionieren und das ziel den
bürgerinnen und bürger den menschen und
damit auch unseren patientinnen und
patienten sichere impfstoffe anzubieten
das konnte heute erreicht werden
jetzt habe ich hier eine stimme die
verlangt zeigt auch mal die waren
stimmen im chat das mache ich sehr gerne
die wir wohl zum beispiel gleich darüber
monika politik monique apocalypse
schreibt gerade mal eine eu genommen
beipackzettel sagt klipp und klar
magenblutungen manchmal tödlich also für
jeden der sich hier darüber aufregt dass
nur eine warnung aufgenommen wird
florian 2 kommentare darunter schreibt
wie stark wirkt sich denn da stoppt aus
heutiger sicht auf die impfkampagne aus
der doktor spieler können wir das schon
beantworten
ich glaube dazu müssen wir gleich die
pressekonferenz des
bundesgesundheitsministers abwarten denn
die bundesregierung muss jetzt stellung
dazu beziehen wie sie mit dem stopp der
impfkampagne umgehen möchte mit dem
astra zeneca impfstoff mann hatte sich
entschieden eine vorübergehende pause
aufgrund der ja am montag gemeldeten
ereignisse der sinus venenthrombosen zu
machen jetzt hat die immer eine
ausführliche prüfung durchgeführt das
paul-ehrlich-institut angestoßen hatte
und ich denke die bundesregierung kann
dann heute auch stellung dazu beziehen
wie es mit der endkampf anje mit dem
astra zenica impfstoff weitergehen soll
eines ist und bleibt klar der
astrazeneca impfstoff ist zumindest im
moment für uns in deutschland nachdem
beyoncé mariah impfstoff der
zweitwichtigste impfstoff und würde er
ausfallen wäre das in jedem fall mit
verzögerungen der impfkampagne in
deutschland verbunden hier noch zwei
weitere fragen an sie einmal von lola
fesch ab wann spricht denn das
nutzen-risiko-verhältnis gegen
eine verwendung von astrazeneca die
frage ist tatsächlich komplexe
diskutierende kennen in der medizin
verschiedene definitionen von sehr
seltenen oder auch häufigere
nebenwirkungen möchte sein ordnung noch
mal geben wir sprechen jetzt über acht
ereignisse in 1,6 millionen geimpften
menschen also sehr seltene ereignisse
dieser sogenannten sinus venenthrombosen
der seltenen und um posen der hirngefäße
bei denen gar nicht abschließend geklärt
wird und geklärt werden kann zum
heutigen zeitpunkt ob sie durch den
astra zeneca impfstoff verursacht sind
oder in zeitlichem zusammenhang damit
aufgetreten sind und obgleich diese
frage nicht beantwortet werden kann ist
die ema und damit auch die gemeinschaft
zur auffassung gekommen dass dieses
arzneimittel weiterhin ein sicheres ist
eine userin habe ja auch angesprochen
werden beipackzettel von arzneimittel
liest wird über sehr viel häufiger
nebenwirkungen stoßen
und ich glaube auch riesen risiko nutzen
bewertung ist eine diskussion die sie
als patientin als patient gerade wenn
sie besorgt sind mit ihrem behandelnden
arzt oder ärztin oder dem in frames
ärzten besprechen sollten sondern gibt
es hier eine andere frage von richter an
sie sehe ich das richtig dass man
geimpft auch wesentlich besser vor longo
witt geschützt ist also vor dem ja doch
sehr langen nachwirkungen einer kur wird
erkrankungen zum beispiel
geschmacksverlust oder desorientierung
oder schwierigkeiten mit mit der
konzentration was können sie da zu sein
tatsächlich ist die tage eine neue
weitere studie erschienen die zeigt dass
fast drei viertel der im erkranken im
krankenhaus behandelten patienten noch
symptome auch noch wochen unseren teilen
nach monaten nach der
krankenhausbehandlung mitbringen
unterschiedlicher schwere wir wissen
heute allerdings noch nicht ob die
impfung auch vor den folgen der kogit
erkrankung schützt was wir allerdings
wissen ist dass alle zugelassenen
impfstoffe die wahrscheinlichkeit der
krankenhausaufnahme und der jakobi
verursachten notwendigkeit der
intensivbehandlung
deutlich reduzieren und damit so gehen
wir zumindest heute davon aus sind auch
mögliche nebenwirkungen und
langzeitfolgen decken oder nicht
nebenwirkungen sondern mögliche
langzeitfolgen der chor wird infektion
sehr viel geringer wahrscheinlich und
studien gezeigt ist das bislang aber
noch nicht
so jetzt in der frage an sie persönlich
die immer wieder hier kommt wenn wir das
mit medizinischem personal zu tun haben
von axa mut haben sie sich auch
astrazeneca impfen lassen oder haben sie
den von johnson & johnson bekommen nach
meiner information gibt es den in der
europäischen union gar nicht noch gar
nicht da ist noch nicht zugelassen wenn
ich da richtig informiert also mit
welchem impfstoff sind sie dann schon
geimpft worden wenn sie schon geimpft
worden sind also ich möchte vielleicht
zunächst mit der frage von johnson
johnson beginnen weil wir eher in der
klinischen prüfungen auch um gegen die
vom rechts der isar der tu in münchen
beteiligt sehen und am zulassungs
programm des johnson johnson präparates
mitwirken er ist allerdings noch nicht
verfügbar in der europäischen union das
wird es mitte ende april der fall sein
also ich geimpft wurde im dezember
vergangenen jahres das privileg hatte
sehr früh geimpft zu werden gab es
damals für uns nur der biontech heißer
impfstoffs ich kann aber ganz klar sagen
dass ich mich heute mit jedem der
zugelassenen und in europa verfügbaren
als neue impfstoffe impfen lassen würde
dann das entscheidende und das hatte ich
eben schon mal versucht herauszuheben
ist dass alle diese impfstoffe wirksam
vor schwerer kost 19 infektion schützen
und alle diese impfstoffe die
zugelassenen in europa auf dem markt
erhältlich sind sind sicher deshalb
lieber zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
lassen sie sich impfen darauf kommt es
an denn wir behandeln gerade auch die
tage in den steigenden infektionszahlen
zunehmend jüngere menschen mit
schwereren verläufen in der klinik da
gab es ja als auch vor kurzem anfang der
woche war das den aufruf der
intensivmediziner den lock down zu
verlängern eben weil die sorge besteht
dass die intensivstation wieder unter
hohem druck kommen teilen sie diese
sorge
die sorge ist aus meiner sicht begründet
wir sehen in einzelnen regionen in
deutschland schon deutlich ansteigende
neuinfektionen since i denn zum teil bis
in den vierstelligen bereich und wir
wissen aus den beiden vorherigen wählen
das mit einigen wochen der verzögerung
dann viele krankenhausaufnahmen
notwendig werden und gerade die
impfstoffe sind ein
die intensivstationen sind die knappste
ressource unsere krankenhaus versorgers
kapazität den menschen die auf
intensivstationen behandelt werden
müssen
verbringen dort in der regel sehr viel
längere zeit als menschen die nur im
krankenhaus behandelt werden müssen
während uns insgesamt gar nicht so viele
intensivbetten zur verfügung stehen
deshalb was die kolleginnen und kollegen
hier fordern ist rechtzeitig maßnahmen
zu ergreifen
das war vor allem die intensivstation
kapazität ausgereizt ist diese bilder
sie erinnern sich vielleicht noch an
bergamo italien als coop 19 begann
möchten wir in deutschland nicht sehen
mir hab ich hatte auch gestern hier den
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten
kretschmann im interview der auch sagte
der dezember das war für ihn ein
schlimmer monat weil eben dort auch die
krankenhäuser in einigen regionen in
sachsen so ausgelastet waren das die
patienten verteilt werden mussten
für alle die sich jetzt gerade erst dazu
geschaltet haben möchte ich noch mal
ganz kurz zusammenfassen was in der
letzten zeit passiert ist wir haben
länger gewartet darauf dass die
pressekonferenz der europäischen
arzneimittelzulassungsbehörde losgeht
der ema nach einer stunde verspätung
ging es dann los um 17 uhr und dort hat
die direktorin der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur ema biskup gesagt
also dass der wirkstoff von astrazeneca
ein wechsel ist was sie sicher vor einer
corona oder fraktionen schützt oder für
einen schweren verlauf dass sie aber
nicht ausschließen können dass es das
risiko von hirnlosen gibt die ja
gemeldet wurden weswegen einige
europäische länder über die hälfte
aufgehört haben mit diesen impfstoff
impfen sie werden weitere analysen auf
den weg bringen das ganze engmaschig
überwachen damit risiken sichtbar werden
aber ihre einschätzung ist astrazeneca
impfstoff bietet eine sichere option um
die bürger innen vor corinna zu schützen
der nutzen sei größer als das risiko
deswegen bleibt ihre zulassung bestehen
und auch die empfehlungen diesen
wirkstoff zu benutzen und wir warten
jetzt darauf dass in berlin die
pressekonferenz von
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
losgeht der sich vermuten wir genau zu
dieser einschätzung der em äußern wird
morgen soll es dann noch mein impfgipfel
geben aber vermutlich wird er sich jetzt
schon dazu ein lassen aber das ganze
kann auch ein belieben das ist jetzt
wieder verschwunden von daher können wir
jetzt weiter doktor christoph spinner
oberarzt am klinikum rechts der isar in
münchen mit fragen löchern
ich glaube ihr habt auch noch einige die
eine frage die immer wieder aufkommt
oder aufgekommen ist war jetzt warum man
nicht zum beispiel wenn es ein risiko
gibt ja noch ein geringes worauf sie
auch hingewiesen haben dass junge
menschen oder besonders junge frauen an
also an dahin thrombose erkranken können
im zusammenhang mit diesem impfstoff
muss man ja immer im absoluten
konjunktiv sagen dass man sagt okay die
impfen weil die bei nicht damit die
kriegen lieber piontek und moderner das
wäre doch eigentlich eine möglichkeit
oder natürlich wäre auch eine
möglichkeit die man diskutieren kann
aber ich darf um noch mal auch für die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer die später
zugeschaltet haben eine einordnung zu
treten wir sprechen von acht möglichen
fällen einer sinus venenthrombose im
zusammenhang mit 1,6 millionen geimpften
menschen dem astra zenica wachsen also
einer sehr sehr seltenen erkrankung und
damit auch eine sehr seltene
nebenwirkungen
es gebe natürlich die möglichkeit jetzt
die priorisierung und dem stoff
zuordnung noch einmal zu ändern aber ich
glaube wir sehen auch dass es vor allem
darauf ankommt den menschen rechtzeitig
und zeitnah ein impf angebot machen zu
können durch die fokussierung vor allem
auf ältere menschen wie er das höchste
risiko haben schwere kurve
19 verläufe zu erleiden ins krankenhaus
zu müssen oder daran zu versterben
wurden die menschen jetzt zunächst mit
einem impfangebot versorgt dass sie eine
entsprechend geringere krankheitsrisiko
haben aber inzwischen können er hat
glücklicherweise auch viele jüngere
menschen aufgrund von systemrelevanz
oder anderen gründen die auch
vorerkrankungen der priorisierten
impfung zugeführt werden ich glaube
solange wir weiterhin so wenige
impfstoffe haben kommt es vor allem
darauf an den menschen ein angebot zu
machen und die immer hat heute noch
einmal bekräftigt dass auch das aus
potzehne galaxien ein sicheres fraktion
ist
und obgleich nicht mit letzter
sicherheit geklärt werden kann ob des
sinus venenthrombosen vielleicht im
zusammenhang mit diesem aufbau zähne car
aktien stehen hat sie ja auch erklärte
die europäische arzneimittelagentur dass
sie weiterhin sehr genau
die gemeldeten und verfügbaren daten der
geimpften menschen in europa verfolgen
wird sie wird weiterhin sehr genau
hinschauen wie entwickelt sich das
sicherheitsprofil und sie hat auch uns
ärztinnen und ärzte aufgerufen dass wir
nebenwirkungen entsprechend melden und
anzeigen müssen und auch basis für mich
wirklich ein positives signal
pharmakovigilanz also die überwachung
von möglichen nebenwirkungen nach der
zulassung von impfstoffen funktioniert
und sie funktioniert wirksam
ich glaube das sind alles nachrichten
die auch das vertrauen der bürgerinnen
und bürger der menschen unserer
patientinnen und patienten in diesen
impfstoff da wieder herstellen sollen
und aus meiner sicht auch können ja da
hat aber das muss man sagen das image
von astra sehen ist schafft doch
ziemlich gelitten in den letzten wochen
hier war noch eine frage die auch
relativ medizinisch wieder ist dann muss
man einmal vorsichtig sein diagnosen
können wir hier nicht stellen also
ferndiagnosen gibt es nicht aber
zumindest gleich eine kurze einschätzung
von ihnen hier gab es die frage was also
mehrere fragen in die richtung was ist
wenn ich ein erhöhtes thromboserisiko
habe oder wenn ich blutverdünnende
mittel nehmen muss aus bestimmten
gründen
würden sie mir dann davon abraten diesen
impfstoff zu nehmen
ganz im gegenteil denn gewesen dass
menschen mit herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen
ein deutlich erhöhtes risiko schwerer
kurs 19 verläufe haben und es wurde in
den letzten tagen oft diskutiert das
risiko bei aktiver coop 19 erkrankung
beim venenthrombosen und auch
lebensbedrohliche lungenembolien zu
erleiden deutlich erhöht wir sprechen
hier von zehn bis zwanzig relevanten
trommeln politischen komplikationen bei
coop 19 patienten in der klinik also
fast in jedem zehnten oder schönsten
fall
und gerade deshalb macht es für menschen
mit herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen erst
recht sind sich rechtzeitig impfen zu
lassen
dima hat heute ja zusammengefasst dass
es dass sie nicht abschließend klären
kann ob diese seltenen formen der hirn
venenthrombose der sinus venenthrombosen
nicht vielleicht im zusammenhang mit dem
ausbau einiger aktien stehe ich noch mal
acht fälle bei 1,6 millionen geben
auf der anderen seite sind thrombosen in
der allgemeinbevölkerung ein vielfaches
häufiger etwa jeder tausendste mensch er
leitet einmal im jahr eine thrombose in
deutschland die mechanismen also die
ursachen und einwänden thrombosen
lungenembolien und den händen prognosen
sind jedoch unterschiedlich also hier
kann man keine ganz pauschale aussage
treffen so und eigentlich warten wir
gerade darauf dass sich in berlin was
tut dass bundesgesundheitsminister jens
spahn vor die kameras tritt und auch
eine presse erklärung abgibt oder ein
statement aber gerade hören wir aus
berlin dass das in der nächsten zeit
nicht der fall sein wird
es wurde um mindestens wohl zwei stunden
verschoben so die information denn das
gesundheitsministerium hat noch nicht
den bericht der ema der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur und möchte den erst
vorliegen haben und sich dann mit den
gesundheitsministern der länder beraten
von daher kann es noch ein bisschen
dauern bis diese pressekonferenz los
geht und ich glaube ganz so viel zeit
wollen wir dann doch nicht verstreichen
lassen das geht zwar viele fragen was
diesen ganzen impfstoff komplex angeht
aber ich glaube auch nach zwei stunden
sind wir damit den meisten fragen durch
ich schaue noch mal ob
ob es eine frage hier gibt also es gibt
jetzt auch fragen haben sie herr doktor
spieler die das ist wie gehen sie mit in
verweigern oben und auch die frage von
kurt bauer hier können die verweigerer
das verhältnis der risiken nicht
abschätzen können sie da noch irgendwie
abschätzen
es ist diese frage hier kurz markiert
können sie dazu irgendwie noch was sagen
er natürlich ich glaube wir stehen
insbesondere jetzt auch als ärztinnen
und ärzte in der pflicht gute über
impfstoffe über ihre sicherheits profile
und die wirksamkeit aufzuklären und
jeder soll sich ein eigenes bild machen
können ob es impfen lassen möchte oder
nicht ich als klinikarzt sehr natürlich
vor allem die schweren fälle auch junge
menschen zum teil unter 30 jahren die
hier in der klinik auf intensivstationen
behandelt werden müssen und das sind
bilder die mich persönlich sehr bewegen
deshalb kann ich jedem selbst nur
eindrücklich und eindringlich raten sich
sehr gut zu überlegen sich entsprechend
impfen zu lassen wenn die zugelassenen
impfstoffe verhindern wirksam schwere
kurvenverläufe und die notwendigkeit der
krankenhausaufnahme wir müssen in jedem
fall auch eine ausreichend gute
immunisierung in der bevölkerung
erreichen die so genannte
herdenimmunität wahrscheinlich übersicht
70 prozent der menschen werden sich
impfen lassen müssen dass wir überhaupt
die chance erhalten zu einem normalen
leben wie zuvor zurückzukehren dass es
überhaupt gelungen ist nicht ab einem
jahr sichere und wirksame arzneimittel
bereitzustellen das finde ich eine
beeindruckende leistung der modernen
medizin und deshalb ist es mir auch ein
anliegen in so wie heute mit ihnen zu
sprechen um über die sicherheit und
wirksamkeit der impfstoffe aufzuklären
ich kann gut verstehen dass die menschen
viele fragen haben aber deshalb gibt es
formate wie dieses um sie zu beantworten
denn am ende soll jeder mündige bürger
zur eigenen entscheidung kommen aber es
sich impfen lassen möchte oder nicht ich
selbst der lebensstil positiv auch heute
viele positiv ist auch heute in der
sprechstunde
viele patientinnen patienten die sich
entweder schon immunisieren lassen
konnten oder bereits angemeldet haben
und das motiviert mich auch als arzt
weiter zeit in die aufklärung zu
investieren
so jetzt gibt es hier greift der
rettungskarte sind ins alberne mit
fragen wie ist mayonnaise auch ein
instrument wäre diese spongebob folge
kennt weiß was gemeint ist aber es gibt
auch noch ein paar ernst gemeinte fragen
von alexander will zum beispiel gibt es
dann im nachhinein die möglichkeit einer
thrombose nachimpfen entgegenzuwirken
das klang so ein bisschen durch hatte
ich das gefühl gerade wenn der
pressekonferenz der ema dass man ja
jetzt um dieses risiko weiß oder dass es
zumindest auftreten könnte dass es einen
zusammenhang geben könnte zu höheren
thrombosen und dass man dadurch dann
schneller handeln kann also ist das
jetzt tatsächlich so dass man mehr
doktor spinner wenn man dann weiß es
könnte ein risiko bestehen so eine
thrombose zu entwickeln man achtet auf
die anzeichen dass man dann auch
schneller handeln kann
also ich glaube was man vielleicht
allenfalls zwischen den zeilen
herauslesen kann ist dass vor allem
ärztinnen und ärzte aber auch
patientinnen und patienten um die
tatsache wissen dass es einen
zusammenhang geben könnte ich versuche
es mal zu übersetzen das bedeutet am
ende wenn stärkste zuvor nicht dagewesen
unbekannte kopfschmerzen oder
ungewöhnliche neurologische symptome mit
lähmungserscheinungen im zusammenhang
mit einer impfung und sie sind zumindest
in den ersten vier bis 16 tagen nach der
ersten impfung beschrieben worden
diese acht berichteten fälle auftreten
dann sollte man zählt zeitnah ärztliche
hilfe suchen auf der anderen seite hat
sich aber vor allem auch nicht bestätigt
generell erhöhtes thromboserisiko
besteht auch diese annahme war er letzte
woche von nordeuropäischen ländern
aufgeworfen und diskutiert worden ist
ein positives zeichen und deswegen an
das auf keinen fall verstanden werden
vorbeugende maßnahmen zu ergreifen ganz
im gegenteil denn blutverdünnende
medikamente erhöhen immer das risiko
dass schwerer zum teil lebensbedrohliche
blutungen auftreten und eine userin
hatte die hypothese mit ibuprofen ja
auch aufgebracht auch über profen hemmt
die blutgerinnung auf bestimmte art und
weise und kann darüber zu blutungen
führen so gilt es natürlich für alle
also ich glaube wer sich impfen lässt
und vor allem auch mit dem abbau weniger
impfstoff hat ihm zu lassen in den
letzten tagen noch sollte sich aus
meiner sicht gerade nach den nachrichten
heute
nicht verunsichern lassen aber wenn in
dem unwahrscheinlichen fall sehr seltene
und neue stärkste kopfschmerzen
auftreten dann sollte natürlich erste
hilfe in anspruch gewöhnliche symptome
aber ansonsten die gute nachricht des
tages
der astra weniger impfstoff ist sicher
und er schützt wirksam vor kurve
bedingter krankenhausaufnahme und tod
so also wie es klingt so als ob die
pressekonferenz des
bundesgesundheitsministers hier
entspannen in berlin noch etwas dauern
kann wir haben jetzt über sehr viele
fragen gesprochen das gibt natürlich
immer noch die spezialfragen wo es dann
um besondere medizinische
vorerkrankungen geht
ich glaube die sollte man dann
tatsächlich wenn man zum impftermin geht
oder einen impftermin vorhat darstellen
sonst kommen wir hier wirklich vom
hundertsten ins tausendste ich würde
sagen ich frag mal kurz in die regie
machen wir diesen stream jetzt zu und
warten darauf dass herr sparen heute
abend wo die kameras tritt
okay der mann im ohr sagt das kann sogar
bis morgen dauern das wissen wir nicht
genau
von daher bedanke ich mich jetzt bei
herrn doktor spinner der spontan für uns
zeit hatte das alles so geduldig zu
beantworten ich kann ihnen mit sein sie
haben einen kleinen fanclub bei uns in
den kommentaren erworben vielen dank für
ihre aufklärungsarbeit und für ihre
geduld und tschüss nach münchen
ich danke ihnen bleiben für alle gesund
ist falsch und dann bedanke ich mich
natürlich auch bei euch und bei ihnen
für fürs zuschauen für das kommentieren
für das fragenstellen dafür sind wir da
ich bin froh dass wir viele fragen
beantworten konnten ich hoffe sie haben
ein bisschen zur aufklärung beitragen
können und schließlich den guten
wünschen von doktorspiele an bleibt alle
gesund und ich würde sagen dann bis zum
nächsten stream wahrscheinlich schon
morgen bis dahin was gut und ist